[Musik]
den verstärkten Kontrollen an der
deutsch-polnischen und
deutsch-tschechischen Grenze
anschließend besteht Zeit für einige
Fragen ja meine Damen und Herren ich
habe ja letzte Woche angeboten in den
Innenausschuss noch mal zu kommen um
über andere Themen zu sprechen die ich
letzte Woche schon kurz angesprochen
hatte da ging es heute vor allen Dingen
um zwei komplexe wie der Pressesprecher
Herr Keil schon gesagt hat nämlich
einmal das Verbot der artgemeinschaft
und vor allen Dingen auch Migration
erweiterte Grenzkontrollen
das Vereinsverbot die artgemeinschaft
haben wir heute eine sektenartige
zutiefst rassistische und antisemitische
Vereinigung verboten das ist ein
weiterer harter Schlag gegen den
Rechtsextremismus und es hat ist ein
weiterer harter Schlag gegen die
geistigen Brandstifter die bis heute
ns-ideologien verbreiten diese
rechtsextremistische Gruppierung hat
versucht durch eine widerwärtige
Indoktrinierung insbesondere von Kindern
und Jugendlichen neue Verfassungsfeinde
heranzuziehen Kern dessen war die
nationalsozialistische Rassenlehre die
artgemeinschaft ist mit vielen
rechtsextremen und neue rechten
Gruppierungen vernetzt diese Vernetzung
verbinden diese Vereinigung verbindet
verschiedene Strömungen der extremen
Rechten und gefährdet damals die
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
in besonderem Maße in Deutschland in den
frühen Morgenstunden heute hat die
Polizei in zwölf Bundesländern
gleichzeitig Durchsuchungsmaßnahmen weil
39 Mitgliedern der Vereinigung
durchgeführt bei diesem Einsatz sind
bundesweit rund 700 Kräfte mit
Unterstützung der Bundespolizei im
Einsatz gewesen mein Dank gilt noch mal
allen Verfassungsschutzbehörden in den
zwölf Bundesländern und natürlich beim
Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und den
unterstützende Maßnahmen durch die
Ermittlungsbehörden in Bund und Land
nach unserem bisherigen Erkenntnisstand
sind unter anderem große Mengen
extremistischer Literatur sowie Gold
Bargeld und ABC Schutzausrüstung
gefunden und beschlagnahmt worden
außerdem wurden waffenrechtliche
Erlaubnisse aberkannt und Schusswaffen
sichergestellt auch diesem Vereinsverbot
gingen wie bei dem Verbot der
Hammerskins letzte Woche eine
umfangreiche und gründliche Vorbereitung
von knapp einem Jahr voraus maßgeblich
waren insbesondere Erkenntnisse des
Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz sowie
der Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz
habe es gerade schon gesagt ich möchte
mich auch heute nochmals für die gute
Zusammenarbeit zwischen Bundes und
Landesbehörden bedanken und wir werden
den Rechtsextremismus auch weiterhin
scharf im Blick haben
das zweite Thema wozu ich Ihnen gerne
berichten möchte was ich im Ausschuss
vorgestellt habe es sind die Bekämpfung
der schleuserkriminalität und der
erweiterten Grenzkontrollen wir müssen
das grausame Geschäft der Schleuser
unbedingt stoppen denn die setzen mit
maximalen Profit Menschen Leben aufs
Spiel deshalb nimmt die Bundespolizei ab
sofort zusätzliche flexible
Schwerpunktkontrollen an den
schleuserrouten an den Grenzen zu Polen
und Tschechien vor diese zusätzlichen
Kontrollen ergänzen die Schleierfahndung
die wir bereits in den letzten Monaten
intensiviert haben so ist die
Bundespolizei im gesamten Grenzgebiet
mit starken Kräften präsent mein Ziel
ist maximaler Ermittlungsdruck auf die
Schleuser und der Schutz der Menschen
die oft ohne Wasser mit kaum Luft durch
die Grenzen geschmuggelt werden mit
unseren Nachbarstaaten Tschechien und
Polen und den Bundesländern Sachsen und
Brandenburg sind wir in engen Kontakt
über diese weiteren Maßnahmen damit sie
auf beiden Seiten möglichst eng
zusammengreifen wir wollen durch
flexible und mobile Kontrollen an
wechselnden Orten Ausweichbewegung der
Schleuser verhindern zugleich sorgen wir
davor dass die Kontrollen im Alltag so
wenig wie möglich Auswirkungen auf die
Menschen und die Wirtschaft haben sie
wissen dass es einmal natürlich extreme
Handelsbeziehungen gibt und natürlich
auch im Alltag Menschen Pflegekräfte
Handwerkerinnen Handwerker auf beiden
Seiten jeweils haben
ich bin der Bundespolizei sehr dankbar
für den starken Einsatz nach den
erheblichen stellensteigerungen in den
letzten Jahren stärken wir auch in
diesem Jahr die Bundespolizei mit
weiteren tausend zusätzlichen Stellen
bei der Bundespolizei damit Sie für Ihre
Aufgaben auch gut gerüstet ist wir sehen
auch jetzt wieder mal wie wichtig dieser
Punkt ist vielleicht gilt für eine
deutliche Verringerung der irregulären
Migration bleibt das gemeinsame
europäische Asylsystem der entscheidende
Schritt damit muss jeder an den
EU-Außengrenzen strikt kontrolliert und
registriert werden wer nur eine geringe
Aussicht auf Schutz in der EU hat muss
an den Außengrenzen ein
rechtsstaatliches Asylverfahren
durchlaufen und bei einer Ablehnung
direkt von dort auch zurückgeführt
werden über das gemeinsame Asylsystem
werden wir morgen in Brüssel weiter
beraten ich treibe dieses Thema weiter
mit voller Kraft voran und ich bin auch
sehr optimistisch dass wir die
europäische Gesetzgebung hierzu
erfolgreich abschließen werden vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
ja auch diese weiteren Maßnahmen von
diesen die sprach die sind auf der
Grenzlinie selbst vorgesehen insofern
werden wir das diese Woche umsetzen
das sind die
in Brüssel noch notifizieren eine Frage
und die zweite wenn sie so positiv sind
dass das geas betrifft
glauben Sie denn die Grünen wäre in
ihrem Blockade über vertretenverordnung
betrifft aufgeben für diese
kurzfristigen zusätzlichen
Grenzkontrollen in Zusammenarbeit mit
beiden Nachbarländern bei der Umsetzung
der Agenda schließen damit eben auch die
ärmeren Staaten die Nachhaltigkeitsziele
erreichen können es fehlen aktuell noch
knapp vier Billionen US-Dollar und damit
diese Lücke geschlossen werden kann muss
auch die Privatwirtschaft mehr Geld in
nachhaltige Projekte investieren nur im
Zusammenspiel der Akteurinnen und
Akteure können wir da wirklich
erfolgreich sein und deswegen ist die
nächste weltbanktagung im Oktober so
wichtig die Weltbank muss eine echte
transformationsbank werden damit mehr
Geld für Armutsbekämpfung Klimaschutz
für Geschlechtergerechtigkeit eingesetzt
werden kann das ist das Ziel der
weltbegriffform die ich eben mit anderen
anteilseignerinnen und eigenen zusammen
angestoßen habe und das ist ein ganz
ganz wichtiger Hebel für die auffolljagd
vielen Dank
ich bitte nun zunächst Fragen zu den
beiden Berichten und den
Geschäftsbereichen der anwesenden
Mitglieder der Bundesregierung zu
stellen und zuerst hat das Wort aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion DR Matthias Mittelberg
Präsidentin herzlichen Dank fürs Wort
ich darf auch für meine Fraktion
erklären dass wir uns freuen dass es den
beiden Ministern gesundheitlich so gut
geht das wäre eigentlich eine
hervorragende Voraussetzung um auch gute
Regierungsarbeit zu leisten da haben wir
allerdings gewisse Zweifel und auch
Fragen und der Bundesminister für
Finanzen hat ja deutlich gemacht dass
die wirtschaftliche Lage in Deutschland
im Moment wirklich ziemlich Sorgen
bereitet die Menschen verlieren massiv
an Kaufkraft und der
Investitionsstandort also ob jetzt
Firmen hier wirklich investieren wollen
der ist deutlich unattraktiver geworden
wir haben die höchsten Strompreise die
dritte höchsten Unternehmen Steuern
weltweit unsere Wirtschaft schrumpft und
jetzt sagen Sie Herr Minister ich mache
jetzt einen
wachstumsschancengesetz und darauf setze
ich meine Hoffnung das wird den Standort
wieder in Schwung bringen
da ist vieles richtig drin in dem Gesetz
aber es hat ein Volumen von gerade
sieben Milliarden jährlich an Entlastung
gleichzeitig fördern wir beispielsweise
eine chip-fabrik in Magdeburg mit 10
Milliarden glauben sie vor dem
Hintergrund dass ihr
wachstumschancengesetz bei dem geringen
Volumen für die gesamte deutsche
Wirtschaft gerade sieben Milliarden ein
Wachstumsschub auslösen kann
Herr Minister
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin lieber Herr
Kollege nein ich habe nicht gesagt dass
ich alle meine Hoffnungen in das
Wachstumschancen und das
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz setze
sondern ich habe beide charakterisiert
als Bausteine einer
angebotsseitigen Strategie um die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres Landes zu
verbessern das genannte Werk in
Magdeburg habe ich hier nicht mit
einbezogen dies geht ja auch zurück auf
eine Entscheidung der Vorgänger
Regierung die diese Regierung nur weiter
verfolgt ich glaube dass wir mit einem
angebotsseitigen
Programm gut beraten sind denn vom
Mangel an Arbeitskräften über Bürokratie
über lange Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren haben wir hier
auch Bremsen bei der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung die zu beseitigen kein Geld
kostet darüber hinaus will ich sagen
dass die Bundesregierung die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung ja auch
dadurch unterstützt dass wir auf
Rekordniveau investieren 54 Milliarden
Euro Übergang im nächsten Jahr im
Vergleich zu 2019 mit 36 Milliarden Euro
eine deutliche Steigerung
[Musik]
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja wir
finden ja den Ansatz mit der
angebotsorientierten Politik auch
richtig aber jetzt stellen wir ja fest
dass gerade ihre Partei auch die FDP mit
ihrer
teilregierungsverantwortung mitwirkt an
lauter Entscheidungen die eigentlich
unseren Standort eher belasten und das
Angebot einschränken die Abschaltung der
drei Kernkraftwerke beschränkt das
Energieangebot und ist gerade kein
Beitrag zur Angebot Steigerung wir
stellen auch noch nichts von schnelleren
Verfahren oder weniger Bürokratie fest
sondern im Gegenteil dass sie bergeweise
in tausenden Größenordnung neue Beamten
eingestellt haben gerade in der
Bundesverwaltung die Menschen in
Deutschland sind mit höheren
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen belastet
und ihre Migrationspolitik Stichwort
Fachkräfte funktioniert ja gerade nicht
sondern die läuft maximal chaotisch und
die Leute lernen nicht in Beschäftigung
sondern landen im Bürgergeld vor dem
Hintergrund frage ich sie
ist der Beitrag
sie haben 2017 gesagt die FDP steht
nicht zur Verfügung für eine Koalition
weil Trend wenn nicht erreichbar sind
glauben Sie denn dass sie diese Trend
wenn in dieser Regierung überhaupt noch
erreichen können als FDP
Herr Kollege Ihre Frage hat sich
offensichtlich an den FDP-Vorsitzenden
gerichtet aber der FDP-Vorsitzende steht
hier nicht Rede und Antwort sondern der
Bundesfinanzminister und der
Bundesfinanzminister sagt erstens dass
er es für richtig hält dass wir
beispielsweise beim Zollstellen aufbauen
denn der Zoll ist ein Partner der
Wirtschaft und unsere Import und
exportorientierte Wirtschaft braucht
eine leistungsfähige
wirtschaftsorientierte Verwaltung zum
zweiten es geht auf eine
Vorgängerregierung zurück auf
Kernenergie und auf Kohle gleichzeitig
bei der Energieerzeugung zu verzichten
diese Regierung hat in Not Zeiten
dagegen die Laufzeit von Kernkraftwerken
einige Monate verlängert wir beenden die
über lange Zeit geübte Praxis der
Vorgängerregierung schneller beim
Ausstieg aus Technologien Entscheidungen
zu treffen als Entscheidungen über den
Einstieg in neue getroffen werden das
bezieht übrigens Technologien die
Heizung und den Verbrennungs Motor mit
ein und das wäre bei Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren schneller sind als
in der Vergangenheit konnten sie im
letzten Jahr besichtigen als es in
Rekordzeit gelungen ist die Fixierung
auf pipeline-versorgung beim Gas durch
flüssiggast Terminals zu ersetzen jetzt
arbeiten wir daran dass das was gelungen
ist als es sein musste dass das auch
dann gelingt wenn der es nur wollen
und da beide jetzt exemplarisch
überzogen haben noch mal der Appell an
alle nächsten fragestellerinnen und
Fragesteller aber auch an die
Bundesregierung bitte an die vorgegebene
Fragezeichen und Antwortzeit halten
dafür schon mal herzlichen Dank im
voraus und die nächste Frage stellt aus
der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Katharina Beck
ja ich hätte gar nicht so eine tolle
Überlappung erwartet zwischen beiden
Ministerien denn es geht ja auch bei
beiden um Finanzierungsfragen und meine
Frage richtet jetzt eine naturgemäß als
finanzpolitische Sprecherin einen
Christian Lindner den Finanzminister und
zwar die Frage nach Wachstum und
Zukunftsorientierung an den
Kapitalmärkten mit dem
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz schaffen wir
bei im Bereich Börse Digitalisierung
sehr gute Fortschritte wenn man uns aber
im Vergleich mit den USA anschaut sind
wir gerade bei mit und vor allem later
stage Venture Capital ein bisschen
hinten dran und da die Frage wie sie die
eigenkapitalmöglichkeiten hier noch
weiter anregen wollen damit wir auch
hier eben nicht im Hintertreffen sind
sondern auch hier führend werden und das
eben auch im Zusammenhang damit dass wir
einmal für die Entwicklungsziele
insgesamt aber eben auch in Deutschland
für Zukunftstechnologien die wir gerade
mühsam ansiedeln natürlich auch noch
mehr Eigenkapital brauchen
Kollegin Beck sie haben völlig zu Recht
einen Vergleich zwischen Deutschland und
Europa und den Vereinigten Staaten
aufgemacht tatsächlich ist es so dass an
öffentlichen Investitionskapital und
Subventionen wir in Europa trotz
Inflation reduction Act der USA kein
Wettbewerbs Nachteil haben im Gegenteil
wir haben mehr öffentliches Kapital auf
dem Tisch als in den USA unser Problem
ist das private Kapital das wir
mobilisieren müssen deshalb habe ich
zusammen mit meinem französischen
Kollegen eine Roadmap ein Fahrplan
vorgelegt zur verwirklichen der capital
marketunion unser Standort Nachteil
gegenüber den USA in Europa ist dass wir
ein fragmentierten privaten Kapitalmarkt
haben der gerade bei den Unternehmen die
sie geschildert haben die große lose
haben die großen Finanzierungsbedarf
haben das bedeutet nicht adäquat der das
die Nachfrage bedient sehen im privaten
Sektor deshalb capital markets Union und
das zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz für den
deutschen Standorte zusätzliche Elemente
die unsere nationale
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit verbessern werden
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
also insgesamt ganz Ziel ungerichtet tut
sich wohl bei later Station
investitionslücke im Vergleich von knapp
100 Milliarden auf und in Bezug auf die
Klimaziele eine von 65 Milliarden und
jetzt einfach noch mal vielleicht die
Möglichkeit noch mehr zu beschreiben was
wir als Bundesregierung Vorhaben um
diese Investitionen dann eben auch zu
entfesseln und zu ermöglichen dass mehr
Eigenkapital Investitionen hier ankommen
plus was auch wichtig ist viele grow UPS
gehen dann doch in die USA wie wollen
wir die hier halten vielen Dank
auf ihre erste Frage bereits ausgeführt
dass ein Kerl Element die Verwirklichung
der Kapitalmarkt Union sei bezogen auf
Deutschland kommen weitere Maßnahmen
hinzu es ist die Erleichterung des
Zugangs auch zu den Börsen als ein
wichtiger
exit-kanal gerade für hoch innovative
Unternehmen wir sorgen dafür dass der
vorstandort Deutschland attraktiver wird
nach dem Vorschlag der Bundesregierung
wird ja endlich beim Management von
Fondsgesellschaften die Umsatzsteuer
entfallen an schwerwiegender Nachteil
für den vorstandort und wir wissen dass
Unternehmen und Fonds dort investieren
wo sie ihren Sitz haben weiteres kommt
hinzu
nächste Frage stellt aus der
afd-fraktion Peter Böhringer
danke Frau Präsidentin geehrter Minister
Lindner die EU-Kommission hat einem
Sommer einen Vorschlag gemacht für eine
aufwuchs des
eine Revision des laufenden
siebenjährigen Finanzrahmens der EU und
das EU-Parlament hat gleich noch darauf
gesattelt und verlangt noch mehr Geld
nun von den Mitgliedstaaten natürlich
auch von Deutschland je nach
Interpretation sind das zwischen
76 und 97 Milliarden Euro eventuell noch
mehr das sind die Waren zahlen die waren
noch nicht mal so in der Presse
für die Ukraine verzinszahlungen auf
unsere
erachtensysteme und sogar illegale
eu-gemeinschaftsschulden und natürlich
für noch mehr Bürokratie in Brüssel
insgesamt ist das nicht nur ein
ungewöhnlicher Vorgang mitten im
laufenden sieben Jahreszeitraum sondern
auch ein sehr ungehöriger Vorgang denn
der Finanzrahmen ist ja auf sieben Jahre
festgezurrt und die EU hat bis 2027 über
zwei Billionen Euro zur Verfügung mit
diesem Finanzamt und mit anderen
Vehikeln meine einfache Frage darum an
Sie als Finanzminister können Sie heute
zusichern dass die Bundesregierung
keiner Mittelerhöhung für die EU bis
2027 zustimmen wird danke
frau Präsidentin Kollege Böhringer
zunächst will ich sagen dass für den
mehrjährigen Finanzrahmen nicht das
Bundesfinanzministerium federführend ist
sondern dass Auswärtige Amt aber diesen
kurzen Hinweis nur vorangetickt will ich
sagen dass für die Bundesregierung
insgesamt völlig außer Frage steht dass
wir weiterhin die
finanzierungsbedürfnisse der Ukraine als
Europäische Union mit unterstützen
müssen das ist zu trennen die
Finanzierung der Ukraine vor
mehrjährigen Finanzrahmen selbst bei
mehrjährigen Finanzrahmen außerhalb der
finanzierungsbedürfnisse der Ukraine ist
die Bundesregierung der Auffassung dass
die EU-Kommission zunächst einmal selbst
Mittel neu priorisieren muss bevor sie
bei den 27 Mitgliedstaaten fragen sollte
nach zusätzlicher Verstärkung
insbesondere sehe ich als Finanzminister
keinen Bedarf nach einem neuen Programm
wie step das Frau von der Leyen auf den
Weg bringen will um Dinge zu finanzieren
die wir nicht kennen und für die wir
längst andere Möglichkeiten haben etwa
im Bereich next generation EU
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen gut
danke sehr sie haben es zwar
eingeschränkt aber wir werden das eng
beobachten ihr beinahe nein nein auch
wenn sie es eingeschränkt haben und
differenziert haben zwischen MFR auf
höchsten und anderen aufwachsen das muss
man schon genau anschauen fast
gleichzeitig hat die EU-Kommission noch
einen weiteren Vorschlag gemacht im
Sommer nämlich die Einführung von drei
ganz neuen abgabekategorien und ich gehe
schon davon aus dass diesmal das BMF
auch wirklich zuständig ist an dieser
Stelle
auf der absurden Basis des CO2 ein falls
bei Importprodukten und auf der Basis
von nur völlig ungenau schätzbaren
privatwirtschaftlichen gewinnen sollen
also neue Gelder an die EU kalkuliert
und abgegeben werden und auch darum was
die gleiche einfache Frage wird die
Bundesregierung die Einführung solcher
neuen eigenmittelkategorien befürworten
unter ihrer Führung im BMF
[Musik]
ist bereits länger vorgesehen gar nicht
zurzeit
das Wirkens dieser Bundesregierung ist
das vorbereitet worden sondern auch
schon unter der Vorgänger Regierung das
kann Teil neuer Eigenmittel sein ist im
Einzelnen zu prüfen äußerst skeptisch
bin ich aber bei der neuen Idee von Frau
von der Leyen das zukünftig von der
europäischen Ebene auf unsere nationale
Unternehmenssteuer direkt zugegriffen
wird ich glaube diesen Plan von Frau von
der Leyen muss man sehr kritisch
beachten ich jedenfalls sehe nicht dass
er Unterstützung finden kann
angestellt aus der SPD-Fraktion dr
Karamba
Dankeschön frau Präsidentin meine Frage
geht an Frau Bundesministerin svena
Schulze die Bundesregierung genieße eine
hohes Ansehen in Afrika insgesamt in
Westafrika insbesondere dank der
Aktivitäten des Bundeskanzler aber auch
ihre Aktivitäten vor Ort wir haben
leider in einigen Regionen die
Instabilität der Ausbreitung
terroristische Gruppen in der seilzone
betreffen zunehmend auch
westafrikanischen Küstenstaaten und da
sind leider leider auch die
marginalisierte Gruppen von Bevölkerung
die ohne Perspektiven da sind die am
meisten betroffen sind deshalb meine
Frage an Sie Frau Bundesministerin wie
können wir zukünftig unser Engagement in
der Science Zone und den Küstenstaaten
versteckt an dem Bedürfnisse diese volle
rabogruppen ausrichten
Abgeordneter vielen Dank für die Frage
die Sahelzone ist wirklich eine wichtige
Zone weil dort nämlich die ärmsten
Menschen der ganzen Erde leben und
deswegen ist es ganz zentral dass wir
mithelfen dass dort Arbeitsplätze für
die vielen jungen Leute entstehen mehr
als die Hälfte der Bevölkerung des unter
25 Jahre alt und deswegen helfen wir
Arbeitsplätze zu etablieren
Sozialsysteme aufzubauen und den Staat
auch auf der lokalen Ebene überhaupt
wahrnehmbar zu machen unter sehr sehr
schwierigen Bedingungen deswegen
brauchen einen langenarten eine gute
Koordination der verschiedenen Geldgeber
in der Region und deswegen habe ich auch
den Vorsitz der Sahel Allianz also der
Allianz der Geber übernommen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
danke Frau Präsidentin Frau Ministerin
inwieweit müssen wir denn auch mögliche
Nachfolge EU-Missionen langfristige
Strategien der integrierte Sicherheit an
der also in die Ursachen der Bekämpfung
der Armut aber auch
Perspektivlosigkeit eingebettet sein
wir sind das Bundesregierung davon
überzeugt dass es für Sicherheit ganz
zentral ist das Außen sicherheits- und
Entwicklungspolitik zusammenwirkt dass
wir alles drei integriert begreifen
deswegen bin ich zum Beispiel im
Frühjahr auch gemeinsam mit dem
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius in
den Sahel gereist deswegen machen wir so
viele Aktivitäten dort auch gemeinsam
dieser integrierte Sicherheitsbegriff
ist etwas was uns auszeichnet und was
jetzt im Sahel auch dazu führt dass wir
nicht nur die kernsaal starten
betrachten sondern eben auch die
sogenannten spill over Effekte die in
die Küstenstaaten hinein nach Ghana nach
Benin hineingehen und unsere Politiken
auch darauf ausrichten in den
Grenzregionen auch wirklich aktiv zu
sein um eben den Ärmsten der Armen dort
zu helfen
nächste Frage stellt aus der Fraktion
DIE LINKE Christian
vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich habe
eine Frage an den Bundesfinanzminister
Herr Lindner sie erinnern sich
sicherlich
an das Jahr 21 da hatten sie noch als
fdp-vorsitzender plakatiert
steuererhöhungen sind die Sabotage am
Aufschwung sie haben mit dem
Haushaltsentwurf jetzt als
Finanzminister
schlagen Sie vor für 27 Millionen
Haushalte die Mehrwertsteuer bei Gas und
Fernwärme von 7 auf 19% zu erhöhen also
plus 12 Prozent und deshalb frage ich
Sie heißt das jetzt dass sie als
Bundesfinanzminister für
Steuererhöhungen mit dem Abschwung
plädieren
lieber Herr Kollege die Bundesregierung
hatte seinerzeit den Bundestag
vorgeschlagen den Mehrwertsteuersatz für
Gas und Fernwärme als
krisenbedingte
entlastungsmaßnahme befristet zu
beschließen
wir haben daneben Strom und
gaspreisbremse eingeführt die die
Belastung der privaten Haushalte und der
Wirtschaft zusätzlich dämpfen sollten
nun hat sich die Preisentwicklung
zum Glück anders dargestellt als
seinerzeit in den schlimmsten Szenarien
vorhergesehen und deshalb hat die
Bundesregierung im Zuge des Beschlusses
des Haushalts Entwurfes 2024 jetzt den
Vorschlag unterbreitet gut drei Monate
eher als geplant auf diesen reduzierten
Mehrwertsteuersatz zu verzichten
zugleich aber als Rückversicherung für
den Fall möglicher ruinöser Preisspitzen
die Strom und gaspreisbremse des
Wirtschaft St abilisierungsfonds
vorzusetzen das ist verantwortbar
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich möchte
noch mal auf die auf das Thema
Verbraucherpreisinflation zurückkommen
wie gesagt wir werden also nicht nur
eine Mehrwertsteuererhöhung haben
möglicherweise nicht nur weiter
Fernwärme Gas Gastro wir haben jetzt
hier CO2-Preis die eine höher steigt
meinen sie auch meinen Sie nicht auch
dass mit diesen Maßnahmen
nicht mehr zusätzlich die Inflation in
Deutschland befeuern und vor allen
Dingen der straffen Zinspolitik der EZB
einen Bären Dienst erweisen
Herr Kollege erstens ist die Haltung der
Bundesregierung bei Gas und Fernwärme
die krisenbedingte Maßnahme zu beenden
zweitens im Fall der Mehrwertsteuer für
die Gastronomie obliegt ist im
Haushaltsgesetzgeber nach der
Steuerschätzung von Ende Oktober darüber
eine definitive Entscheidung zu treffen
drittens der preisfahrt beim CO2-Preis
ist niedriger als der preisfahrt der
Vorgängerregierung das heißt wir machen
weniger als ursprünglich im Bag geplant
und nicht zuletzt diese Regierung hat
mit dem inflationsausgleichsgesetz die
ganze Breite der Gesellschaft der
arbeitenden Bevölkerung bei der Steuer
entlastet und Kaufkraftverluste zu
dämpfen
nächste Frage stellt aus der
FDP-Fraktion Anja Schulz
bitte vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine
Frage richtet sich an den
Bundesfinanzminister das
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz wurde
bereits angesprochen ist soll
Wachstumsimpulse setzen den Finanzmarkt
modernisieren und vor allem auch bessere
Bedingungen für Start-ups schaffen wo
stehen wir denn in Deutschland im
Bereich der Start-ups im Vergleich zu
anderen EU-Staaten und wie kommt es dass
Unternehmen zwar oft in Deutschland
Gründen am Ende dann aber gegebenenfalls
in anderen Ländern an die Börse gehen wo
sehen sie da Handlungsbedarf
Deutschland hat ungenutztes Potenzial im
Bereich von Startup Unternehmen der
Bundeskanzler hat ja in seiner
Regierungserklärung nochmal zur
Erinnerung uns allen gerufen er hat
seinerzeit gesagt wir wollen es
attraktivster Standort für Start-ups und
Wachstumsunternehmen San wir müssen
jetzt an der ganzen Bandbreite arbeiten
natürlich leiden diese Unternehmen daran
dass sie hier nicht genug Fach und
Führungskräfte finden deshalb bemühen
wir uns ja um Bekämpfung
illegaler Migration aber Erleichterung
qualifizierter Einwanderung die
Mitarbeiter Kapitalbeteiligung führen
wir jetzt neu ein lösen insbesondere die
sogenannte drei inka-problematik was ein
unglaublicher Wettbewerbsnachteil
gegenüber anderen Standorten war stock
option Programme gerade für die Talente
die dort Beschäftigung
in Erwägung ziehen ganz starker Faktor
sich dafür zu entscheiden und nicht für
ein etabliertes Unternehmen und der zu
Gang zu Börse und zu den großen
Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten Hemd
ebenfalls in Deutschland das Wachstum
das gehen wir auch an
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
wenn wir den Referentenentwurf
vergleichen mit dem aktuellen
Gesetzesentwurf gibt es da ja vor allem
im Bereich der Kleinanleger und der das
privaten Kapitals einige Änderungen ich
denke da an die
verlustverrechnungskreise für
Aktiengeschäfte inwieweit sehen sie da
weiterhin Handlungsbedarf
also warum der Tag war so schön warum
jetzt ausgerechnet an der Stelle Salz in
die Wunde gerieben werden muss spaß
beiseite
der Gesetzentwurf der im Deutschen
Bundestag vorgelegt worden ist ist das
Ergebnis der Ressortabstimmung innerhalb
der Bundesregierung seitens des
Bundesfinanzministeriums wären noch
weitere Optionen denkbar gewesen bei der
Frage der Spekulationsfrist beim Verkauf
von Wertpapieren bei dem
verlustverrechnungskreis der zum Teil
paradoxe Ergebnisse hat und auch zu
Rechtsprechung geführt hat insofern hat
der Gesetzgeber noch anders zur weiteren
Verfolgung des Regierungsentwurfs
schön dass ich dabei angeschaut werde
wir kommen nun zu fragen zu den
vorangegangenen Kabinettssitzungen zur
weiteren Geschäftsbereichen sowie zu
allgemeinen Fragen und zuerst stellt die
Frage aus der cdu/csu-fraktion Volkmar
klein
meine Frage richtet sich an Frau
Ministerin Schulze und Frau Ministerin
es ist ja schon schlimm genug dass der
entwicklungsetat den sie dem Parlament
vorgeschlagen haben zum dritten Mal in
Folge deutlich sinken soll aber richtig
dramatisch ist ja eigentlich dass sie
auch dabei dann noch die falschen
Prioritäten setzen und ganz besonders
beim krisentitel und da wo es um
Ernährung geht kürzen das World
food-programm der Vereinten Nationen
warnt ja bereits mit eindeutigen Worten
davor dass es wahrscheinlich dann
Millionen von Menschen aus der
Versorgung komplett herausnehmen muss
oder die entsprechenden Rationen
deutlich kürzen muss und trotzdem kürzen
Sie genau bei den haushaltstiteln bei
denen es um Ernährung geht warum hat das
bei ihnen keine Priorität warum sind
diese Menschen ihnen offensichtlich egal
vielen Dank für die Frage sie kennen den
Haushalt des BMZ viele viele Jahre und
sie wissen dass es nur eine begrenzte
Flexibilität gibt wenn man nicht zusagen
die wir in Regierungsverhandlungen
gegeben haben einfach wieder
zurücknehmen will deswegen ist der Titel
der sich damit beschäftigt auf das was
wir jetzt noch nicht voraussehen können
reagieren zu können der Titel wo man am
ehesten Geld runter nehmen kann wir
kürzen nicht bei dem Bereich der
Ernährung wenn man einer ein deutlichen
Schwerpunkt darauf gesetzt
ernährungssysteme zu verändern und zwar
nicht einfach nur kurzfristig Hilfe in
Länder zu liefern sondern eben zu helfen
dass dort ernährungssysteme entstehen
die die Menschen unabhängiger machen und
wir haben damit große Erfolge gerade mit
dem Welt Ernährungsprogramm ist es uns
in der Sahelzone gelungen der Ebene der
Dörfer Projekte voranzubringen die dazu
beitragen dass bei der nächsten Dürre
Dürre 80% dieser Dörfer keine weitere
Unterstützung brauchen also das was wir
da tun da sind wir international
anerkannt wir sind einer der größten
Geldgeber und diejenigen die wirklich
die Ideen in der Welt voranbringen wie
der Hunger nachhaltig bekämpft werden
kann
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
in Österreich ich muss sie da aber ein
Stück korrigieren weil der Titel der
sonderinitiative wird um 79 Millionen
gekürzt wo es um Ernährung geht das
haben Sie möglicherweise übersehen aber
die Frage ist doch ist Ihnen denn
bewusst dass die Menschen die hungern
natürlich viel eher bereit sind ihre
Heimat zu verlassen sich für den Fluch
für die Flucht zu entscheiden und auf
den gefährlichen Weg nach Europa zu
machen halten Sie denn das vor dem
Hintergrund
ihrer haushaltsentscheidungen dann noch
für sachgerecht
Abgeordneter klein ist freut mich sehr
dass die sonderinitiativen bei ihnen
plötzlich so eine große Aufmerksamkeit
genießen das habe ich aus vergangenen
Zeiten anders in Erinnerung aber der
Großteil meines Etats der Großteil
meines etas setzt sich für vier
Schwerpunkte ein das ist der Kampf gegen
Homer und Armut das ist der eine just
transition das ist der Aufbau von
Gesundheitssystem und es ist
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit das findet
eben nicht nur in sondern Initiativen
Stadt und international werden wir dafür
gelobt wie viel Geld wir genau in diese
Bereiche investieren aber wenn es um die
Fragen geht warum müssen Menschen von zu
Hause fliehen dann sind es vor allen
Dingen die Klimaveränderungen die dazu
führen dass eben Landwirtschaft kaum
noch möglich ist dann sind es Krisen und
Konflikte und deswegen ist das was wir
in Deutschland tun präventiv langfristig
Arbeiten ein Beitrag zufrieden
sorry das ist eben genau das Richtige
ich habe zu diesem Thema eine weitere
Nachfrage gesehen von dem genau
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin ja Frau
Ministerin zu ihrer Erinnerung die
sonderinitiativen wurden von ihrem
Vorgänger Gerd Müller ins Leben gerufen
also durchaus Mitglied der
cduc-su-fraktion gewesen also von daher
hatten die immer große Aufmerksamkeit
aber ich habe bei konkrete Nachfrage und
zwar zum programmperspektive Heimat denn
wenn ihnen die fluchtursachenbekämpfung
wirklich wichtig ist dann stelle ich mir
schon die Frage warum sie genau dieses
Programm einstellen und die zweite Frage
sie haben gesagt sie müssen beim Wald
food-programm kürzen wieso kriegt denn
der Bereich Öffentlichkeitsarbeit in
ihrem Haus einen kräftigen aufwuchs und
des der Bereich Armut und Hunger wird
gekürzt
sehr geehrter Herr Abgeordneter sie
wissen dass der Gesamthaushalt schrumpft
der gesamten Bundesregierung und
natürlich muss dann auch der Etat des
BMZ einen Beitrag zur Konsolidierung
leisten der Anteil meines Hauses am
gesamt Etat bleibt gleich trotzdem haben
wir weniger Geld zur Verfügung wir
setzen ist aber genau an den richtigen
Stellen an und wir setzen es genau da an
wo ist die meiste Wirkung hat wo wir es
möglichst effizient einsetzen können
über 70% der Menschen die fliehen müssen
fliehen nicht nach Europa sondern
fliehen in ihre Nachbarländer fliehen in
Entwicklungsländer und deswegen helfen
wir genau vor Ort dass die Menschen dort
versorgt werden können dass sie dort
bleiben können dass sie Wasserversorgung
haben dass sie Ernährung Zugänge haben
und das ist zentral und bitte auf die
Zeit achten danke
sie können nicht noch mal fragen sie
haben nur eine Nachfrage weil wir immer
noch beim gleichen Thema sind und ich
habe eine weitere Nachfrage von Herrn
Friedhof bitte Frau Ministerin sie haben
gerade das Thema Hunger erwähnt mich
würde interessieren wie sehen Sie die
Eigenverantwortung der Länder gerade im
Bereich der Landwirtschaft bezüglich der
Entwaldung in genau diesen Ländern wir
stellen fest dass gerade in diesem
Bereich Afrikas teilweise es Länder gibt
die zu 60 bis 80 Prozent in
waldungsprobleme haben das führt dazu
dass der fruchtbare Boden abgetragen
wird das führt dazu dass das Wasser
versinkt wie sehen Sie die
Eigenverantwortung gerade diesbezüglich
bevor sie immer mit ihrer
Mensch gemacht und Klimawandel Ideologie
auf uns einschlagen wie sehen Sie die
Eigenverantwortung vergessen in diesem
Bereich
die wissenschaftslage ist da vollkommen
klar der Klimawandel ist real,-
und natürlich gibt es eine
Eigenverantwortung in den Ländern aber
wir haben ja gerade darüber gesprochen
dass das auf die ärmsten Länder dieser
Welt sein dass sie mit dem Notwendigsten
kämpfen und dass sie dann Unterstützung
brauchen um Wälder zu erhalten und
wieder aufzubauen ich glaube das ist
selbstverständlich und das ist ein
wesentlicher Beitrag den wir auch
international leisten
sie können auch nicht nachfragen weil
sie hatten jetzt ihre Nachfrage jetzt
gehe ich habe nämlich noch weitere
Nachfragen zu diesem Thema war das noch
mal eine Nachfrage der Kollegin aus der
SPD
ganz herzlichen Dank das gibt mir noch
mal die Möglichkeit die Frau Ministerin
nach dem Zusammenhang zwischen Ernährung
Souveränität und Absicherung und der
feministischen Perspektive in der
Entwicklung Zusammenarbeit zu fragen und
wie da die Pläne sind in ganz oft sind
es ja gerade die Frauen die für die
Ernährung der Familie in den
Entwicklungsländern zuständig sind und
deswegen ist es so wichtig auch da gute
Ansätze zu haben und ich möchte Sie
fragen welche Ansätze das BMZ in dem
Bereich verfolgen und vor allen Dingen
sie als Ministerin vorantreiben
sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete ja gerade
im Bereich der Landwirtschaft ist es
ganz zentral auf Frauen zu setzen weil
das sind die nur hauträgerin das sind
traditionell diejenigen in diesen
Ländern die sich um die Ernährung
kümmern und deswegen ist es ganz zentral
sich für Landrechte für Frauen
einzusetzen darauf zu achten dass Sie
Zugang zu Saatgut haben und dass sie
eben die Möglichkeit haben ihre
Potenziale auch wirklich zu entfalten
deswegen ist das ein ganz zentraler
Punkt in unserer
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
zu der aktuellen Hauptfrage habe ich
noch eine Nachfrage aus der afd-fraktion
ja vielen Dank Frau Ministerin sie
hatten gerade ausgeführt dass
klimaflucht eine große Rolle spielt wir
wissen heute relativ genau gerade in
entwicklungspolitischen Debatten dass
der Großteil eben nicht angibt aus
Klimaveränderung zu flüchten sondern
dass es ganz überwiegend ja ganz
überwiegend darum geht Rücküberweisungen
in Heimatländer vornehmen zu können also
warum stellen sie sich nicht diese
Realität und was gedenken Sie konkret
dafür zu tun um Rücküberweisungen als
Anreiz für Migration zu reduzieren
Abgeordnete ich habe gerade darüber
gesprochen dass 70 Prozent der Menschen
die fliehen müssen dass in ihrer in
ihren Nachbarregionen tun also vor allen
Dingen in Entwicklungsländer selber
Flehen und dass wir da vor allen Dingen
helfen und dass der Klimawandel dazu
führt dass dürren das Trockenheit
zunimmt in Teilen der Welt oder eben
Starkregen und Überflutung ist aber das
braucht man in Deutschland niemanden
mehr zu erklären wir hatten gerade in
den Jahrestag der Katastrophe an der AH
und wissen alle noch sehr genau was das
für die Menschen bedeutet
so da ich keine weiteren Nachfragen habe
gehe ich zur nächsten Fragestellerin aus
der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Susanne Menge
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin Schulze
wir haben zahlreiche
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen
die sich ähm
entwicklungspolitischen Bildungsbereich
in Deutschland engagieren
die dort geleistete wichtige Arbeit die
wir gar nicht oft genug hoch
wertschätzen können ist ein Standbein
für unsere solidarische Gesellschaft und
auch für unsere demokratische Ordnung
das Promotoren in Programm möchte ich an
dieser Stelle besonders hervorheben und
schließe meine Frage an wie planen Sie
diese Organisation und ihr Engagement
für die Agenda 2030 zu stärken
beziehungsweise wie werden sie
verhindern dass es zu eklatanten
Kürzungen und personalstreichungen kommt
ganz herzlichen Dank für die Frage an
die zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen sind in der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit sehr sehr
wichtig sind brückenbäure in die
Entwicklungsländer hinein sie können
auch in Kontexten arbeiten in denen das
für uns als regierungsvertreterinnen und
Vertreter deutlich schwieriger ist weil
sie eben andere Zugänge in die
Gesellschaften haben und deswegen war es
mir sehr wichtig dass wir auch Geld zur
Verfügung stellen für die Arbeit im
Ausland aber auch hier in Deutschland im
Inland wir haben eine Milliarde in
diesem Etat in diesem laufenden Jahr
führte wegesellschaftliche Organisation
und wenn das Parlament meine Vorschlag
folgt werden wir auch im nächsten Jahr
weiterhin eine Milliarde zur Verfügung
haben die zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen wünschen sich natürlich
mehr Geld ich denke aber in der heutigen
Zeit ist es schon ein Schritt nach vorne
wenn man es schafft den Beitrag stabil
zu halten
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
ich möchte gerne die Nachfrage an
unseren Minister
weiterreichen sehr geehrter Herr Lindner
sehen Sie diese wichtige Aufgabe genauso
und stehen sie hinter der Finanzierung
der zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisation
Frau Kollegin mit Respekt für das
Ressortprinzip kann ich nur ausführen
dass die Kollegin natürlich die
sogenannte schichtungsfreiheit hat im
Rahmen also der vom Finanzministerium
vorgegebenen ausgabeobergrenze setzt sie
weil sie die fachliche Expertise hat
ihre Schwerpunkte
ich sehe dazu im Moment keine Nachfragen
dann stellt die nächste Frage aus der
afd-fraktion Jan Wenzel Schmidt
sehr geehrter Herr Bundesfinanzminister
der effektive Zinssatz der KfW für
Studienkredite hat sich innerhalb kurzer
Zeit mehr als verdoppelt lag dieser im
Oktober 2021 noch bei 3,76% waren es im
April 2023 bereits
7,82%. was unternimmt die
Bundesregierung damit die KW Kredite für
Studenten nicht zur Schuldenfalle werden
sehr geehrter Herr Kollege die KfW hat
zwar eine exzellente
Glaubwürdigkeit bei den Kapitalmärkten
exzellentes Rating dennoch hat sie sich
auch zu refinanzieren deshalb hat die
allgemeine Zinsentwicklung auch
Auswirkungen auf die KfW die Bundeswehr
die Bundesregierung prüft aber
fortwährend ob bei Programmen angesichts
der Zinsentwicklungen Anpassung
notwendig ist weil es ja hier soziale
Absichten gibt etwa dem Zugang zum
Studium nicht zu erschweren weil ich
noch 30 Sekunden übrig habe erlaube ich
mir einen kurzen Rückgriff auf die
Debatte eben das internationale
Engagement der Bundesregierung muss
immer im Kontext gesehen werden wenn
also nach der Frage von Bekämpfung Armut
und Ernährung gefragt wird muss ich
darauf hinweisen dass die
Bundesregierung das food Schock window
des Internationalen Währungsfonds aus
dem Länder die Probleme an den
nahrungsmittelmärkten haben unterstützt
werden dass also es im Zusammenhang zu
sehen
dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
[Applaus]
sie haben sie haben ja nun den EZB
Leitzins angesprochen der liegt aktuell
bei 4,5% aber wir haben nun eine
Zinsentwicklung für die Studienkredite
von
7,82%, das ist eine große Differenz sie
selbst sind im Verwaltungsrat der KfW
sogar Vorsitzender planen Sie selbst
eine Initiative um hier die Studenten zu
entlassen
als
veranstaltungsratsvorsitzender bin ich
ja nicht in die Gestaltung der
operativen Programme eingebunden ich
kann Ihnen nur für die Bundesregierung
insgesamt und für die jeweils
zuständigen Ressorts für die einzelnen
Programme der KfW sagen dass wir sie
fortwährend prüfen ob sie ihrem Zweck
dienen ob sie den Zweck erfüllen und bei
den Studienkrediten ist offensichtlich
dass die Hürde für die Aufnahme eines
Studiums gesenkt werden soll deshalb
werden solche Fragen fortwährend
evaluiert da wo erforderlich wird
nachgesteuert
[Musik]
aber zu diesem Thema eine Nachfrage
gesehen
das Abgeordneter
ja vielen Dank Frau präsid na ja vielen
Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrter
Minister Lindner ist klüpft an das Thema
Inflation Zinsentwicklung Jungs steht
oder heute im Handelsblatt das ist wohl
wieder ein internen krachgeber herr
Scholz bremst sie aus weil sie ein Teil
der CO2 Bepreisung gerne das sogenannten
als Klimagerät ab 20 25 zurückgeben
möchten denn sie sprachen davon ist darf
nicht mehr belastet werden fakt ist 10
um 10 € wird die CO2 Bepreisung steigen
auf 40 € hier Tonne das heißt beim
Benzin 11 Cent beim Diesel 10 Cent
werden Sie also bereit dann wenigstens
die Autofahrer die Pendler zu entlasten
und die Entfernungspauschale zum ersten
Januar nächsten Jahres kräftig zu
erhöhen Herr Minister ich sehe da kein
Sachzusammenhang zur Ursprungsfrage aber
wenn Sie möchten können Sie das gerne
kurz beantworten für mich beides
Inflation und das ist ein großer
Sachzwang das ist die Metaebene frau
Präsidentin eben nicht
frau Präsidentin mit Ihrem
Einverständnis kann ich kurz reagieren
Herr Kollege der preisfahrt des
bundesemissionshandelsgesetzes ist
unterhalb des preispates den die
Vorgängerregierung vorgesehen hat der
CO2-Preis des Jahres 2024 war nach den
ursprünglichen Plänen weitere 5 € höher
als er es jetzt ist zweitens wir
arbeiten intensiv am Klimagerät die
Verabredung der Koalition ist in dieser
Wahlperiode steht der Mechanismus zur
Verfügung in der nächsten Wahlperiode
wird erstmals ausgezahlt ich glaube wir
können schneller sein technisch wird es
schon 2025 also früher als von der
Koalition geplant möglich sein Klima
Geld auszuzahlen im Jahr 2025 rechnen
wir mit 13 Milliarden Euro Einnahmen aus
dem nationalen CO2-Preis wenn es nur
nach dem BMF ginge würde ein größerer
Teil davon pro Kopf an die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger ausgezahlt
jetzt frage ich zu dieser Meter Ebene
noch gibt's dazu noch eine Nachfrage
das ist nicht der Fall dann gehe ich zur
nächsten Fragestellung die kommt aus der
SPD-Fraktion von Tim klyssendorf
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundesfinanzminister in der
Steuerpolitik sind wir ja ich würde mal
sagen in freundschaftlichem Austausch
auf dem Weg noch zu vielen Einigungen zu
kommen
eine Einigung haben wir aber im
Koalitionsvertrag miteinander vereinbart
und zwar ist es die Umsatzsteuer
Betrugsbekämpfung wir haben im bereits
angesprochenen wachstumschancengesetz
die Einführung der verbindlichen
E-Rechnung vereinbart meine Frage ist
hinsichtlich dessen dass es ja nur der
erste Schritt auf dem Weg zu einem
elektronisch Meldesystem sein kann wie
ist der aktuelle Stand zum
elektronischen Meldesystem in der
umsatzsteuerbetrugsbekämpfung und können
Sie die Schritte aufzeigen die die
Bundesregierung unternimmt um dort das
Ziel zu erreichen
ja sehr geehrter Herr Kollege sie haben
ja
dankenswerterweise darauf hingewiesen
dass wir eine wichtige Voraussetzung zur
Bekämpfung des Umsatzsteuerbetrug ist
jetzt erreichen dadurch dass wir in
Bereich der Rechnungslegung elektronisch
werden das werden wir verbinden damit
dass wir auch entsprechende
austauschmechanismen schaffen so dass
eine Auswertung möglich wird dazu sind
die unterschiedlich befassten
Arbeitsebenen der Bundesregierung im
intensiven Austausch und wollen
baldmöglichst auch dann eine konkreten
Fahrplan vorlegen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank für die Ausführung mich
würde auch noch mal interessieren im
Detail wie die Abstimmung auf
europäischer Ebene läuft sie wissen das
auch die europäische Ebene Plan für die
transnationalen Interaktionen dort ein
verbindliches Meldesystem einzuführen
vielleicht können sie da noch etwas zur
Abstimmung auf europäischer Ebene sagen
Herr Kollege auf europäischer Ebene sind
wir intensiv miteinander im Gespräch
setzen ja auch europäische Vorgaben hier
national um und das gemeinschaftliche
Ziel den auch grenzüberschreitenden
Umsatzsteuer Betrug zu bekämpfen
beispielsweise war ich selbst im
vergangenen Jahr mehrfach im Gespräch
mit den entsprechenden Behörden auf der
europäischen Ebene um zu schauen wie
auch auf der operativen Ebene ist noch
besser gelingen kann dafür zu sorgen
dass das Recht durchgesetzt wird denn
die gemeinsame Auffassung der
Bundesregierung ist Steuern nicht
erhöhen sondern Steuerrecht durchsetzen
gibt es dazu eine Nachfrage
sehe ich nicht dann gehe ich zur
nächsten Frage über aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE Ina Latendorf
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine
Frage richtet sich an Frau Ministerin
Schulze
es ist ja schon die Haushaltskürzung
angesprochen da liegen wir bei 25
Prozent weniger bmz-gelder
bis 2025 gegen hoher gegen Klimakrise
gegen Ungerechtigkeit und Sie haben ja
jetzt ein ein neues Credo reingebracht
und wollen die Privatwirtschaft stärker
ins Boot holen sie nennen das Business
and development mehr Business weniger
Staat das soll die Probleme lösen
aus unserer Sicht ist aber das Business
selbst ja mit dran schuld dass Hunger
Klimakrise und Ungerechtigkeit sich so
stark ausgeweitet haben ich möchte zu
sprechen kommen auf die deutsche
Entwicklung Zusammenhalt in der
Gesundheitsfinanzierung da gibt es jetzt
zwei frische Studien von der rosa
luxemburg-stiftung und von oxfarm
beide Studien zeigen dass die Hälfte der
Finanzierung die über die deutsche
Entwicklungsgesellschaft im globalen
Süden für die Gesundheit ausgegeben
werden an Privatfirmen fließen
Krankenhäuser werdenden teure Stadtteile
gesetzt und die Strukturen sind damit
unerreichbar für
ärmere Leute können Sie sagen warum das
was durch die Idee
seit Jahren immer wieder
praktiziert wird eigentlich die Ziele
der
ez-kontag gariert und warum ist unter
ihrer Führung daran nichts geändert
worden
sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete die DG ist
der Privatsektor der KfW die ist
eindeutig dafür gegründet privat das
Engagement sozusagen voranzubringen und
ich glaube wir sind uns doch alle einig
das für die globalen Probleme für das
was ich eben genannt habe für den
Klimaschutz für die
biodiversitätserhalt für Aufbau von
Gesundheitssystemen und Sozialsystem das
ist nicht reicht nur auf das öffentliche
Geld zu setzen das ist einfach zu wenig
wir müssen auch das private Kapital in
nachhaltige Bereiche lenken wenn auf der
einen Seite weiter in
Kohlekraftwerke investiert wird und auf
der anderen Seite versucht wird das zu
verhindern dann ist es benutzt das nicht
wir brauchen wirklich auch das private
Kapital in der richtigen Richtung und ja
dafür setze ich mich auch als
entwicklungsministerin ein
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen und
bitte auf die Zeit achten
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin vielen
Dank Frau Ministerin für die Antwort sie
hatten ja schon gesagt sozusagen auch
privates Geld in die richtige Richtung
jetzt haben wir aber gerade eine neue
Recherche von Korrektiv vorliegen wo die
die ja gestern erst erschienen ist und
wo Alarm geschlagen wird DEG Geld an
Grundbesitzer ein paar Geweih dort wird
massiv mit diesem Geld Regenwald
abgeholzt das konterkariert eigentlich
das was sie gerade sagen in die
richtigen Richtung und da noch mal die
Frage gibt es die Möglichkeit darauf
hinzuwirken denn KfW und DEG sind ja
nicht im luftleeren Raum sondern in
unserem
herzlichen Dank für die Frage es gibt
bei der DEG einen unabhängigen
Beschwerde beschwerdemmechanismus und
wir gehen solchen Hinweisen die es gibt
dann in den Gremien nach und überprüfen
ob das wirklich Fakten sind
gibt es zu diesem Thema weitere
Nachfragen dass ich nicht dann gehe ich
zur FDP-Fraktion und da stellt die
nächste Frage dr Christoph Hoffmann
meine Frage geht an Frau Ministerin
Schulze der Bundeskanzler hat gestern
abend hier in Berlin eine
bemerkenswerte Rede gehalten zum Thema
Armutsbekämpfung und Erreichung der
Social Development Gold der sagte dass
die Globalisierung dazu geführt hat das
1,2 Milliarden Menschen aus der Armut
befreit werden konnten aber das ist dazu
natürlich auch privates Geld braucht und
nur die Mobilisierung von privaten Geld
letztendlich dazu führen kann die
Bedürfnisse im globalen Süden wirklich
zu befriedigen und das ist auch die
Aufholjagd von der sie vorher gesprochen
hat die wir jetzt angehen müssen und
gleichzeitig habe ich gehört im Kongo
bei einer entwicklungsministerin dass
sie sagt eure deutschen kleinen Projekte
sind ja nett aber sie helfen unsere
Entwicklung eigentlich nicht wirklich
wir brauchen die großen Projekte meine
Frage wie schaffen wir Finanzierung für
die Investitionen die nötigen
Investitionen in wirtschaftlich
schwachen Ländern
Abgeordneter erst einmal herzlichen Dank
für das Lob für die Rede des Kanzlers
gestern ich fand das auch sehr
bemerkenswert dass er bei diesem
Jahresempfang gesprochen hat und doch
mal die Entwicklungspolitik als Ganzes
dargestellt hat und ich würde Ihnen
absolut zustimmen es muss uns gelingen
auch große Projekte als demokratische
Staaten zu stimmen weil wir sind nicht
ohne Konkurrenz es sind auch noch andere
in der Welt unterwegs und deswegen gibt
es mit Team Europe jetzt auch
europäische Initiativen die wir
zusammenbinden und es gibt eben auch G7
Initiativen einfach um größere Projekte
gemeinsam stemmen zu können
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Nachfrage also ich habe das Beispiel der
planungsministerin aus dem Kongo genannt
das Land also ein schlechtes Rating das
eigentlich keine Kredite möglich sind
auch wenn eine deutsche Firma da was
bauen will es ist nicht möglich weil es
dieses Unternehmen Nieten bekommt wie
können wir dieses Problem angehen
Abgeordnete sie beschreiben ist absolut
richtig gerade in den
Entwicklungsländern ist es so dass die
Banken ein schlechtes Rating haben dass
dazu führt dass sehr hohe Zinsen
genommen werden müssen für Kredite und
das einfach unattraktiv ist und deswegen
müssen wir es schaffen über die Weltbank
stärker Kredite auch für solche
Investitionen in Anspruch nehmen zu
können die Staaten zu befähigen
Finanzsysteme aufzubauen Banksysteme
aufzubauen Steuersysteme aufzubauen um
eine Stabilisierung der Länder zu
erreichen so dass sie dann auch wieder
für privates Kapital attraktivere
Rahmenbedingungen haben
gibt es dazu zu diesem Thema eine
Nachfrage
ist ja oft so danke erstmal sehr oft so
dass Kredite ausgereicht werden an
Länder der Dritten Welt oder globalen
Süden heute sagt und diese Kredite
werden da nicht zurückgezahlt die türmen
sich auf die Kredite und irgendwann
kommt zu einem Schulden Erlass wir haben
danach gefragt da sind ja viele
Milliarden Euro in den letzten Jahren
erlassen worden meine Frage ist durch
diese Art der Entwicklungshilfe Politik
welche Länder in Afrika haben sie bisher
nachhaltig stabilisiert
Abgeordnete erstmal kann ich ihre
Analyse so nicht zustimmen es ist nicht
so dass immer einfach nur Schulden bei
einem Land aufgehäuft werden es ist so
dass viele der Entwicklungsländer sehr
stark bei China verschuldet sind 17% z.B
deswegen ist nicht einfach mehr möglich
ist Schuldenerlasse zu machen weil das
bedeuten würde dass wir als China sich
daran nicht beteiligt die Schulden für
China übernehmen das wollen wir aber
nicht deswegen gibt es das common
framework deswegen gibt es diese
gemeinsame Aktivitäten um die
Entschuldigung von Ländern
voranzubringen dass das ein zentraler
Punkt ist das arme Länder die jetzt
gerade in der Kurve Pandemie noch mal
sich weiter verschulden mussten dass wir
den helfen müssen wieder nach vorne zu
kommen ich glaube das ist in der Welt
nahezu umstritten
und da sehe ich eine noch letzte
schnelle Nachfrage von Herrn
ja vielen Dank ich will da noch mal
einhaken es ist so dass eben sehr wohl
alle zehn Jahre circa ein Schulden
Erlass oder Schuldenschnitt stattfindet
und ich frage mich natürlich wie wollen
sie die Situation verbessern wenn sie
jetzt auch noch die Weltbank zu Klima
Bank umbauen wollen und damit die
Vorgaben erhöhen und es noch schwieriger
machen die Attraktivität der Bank
beizubehalten gerade vor dem Hintergrund
dass eben der Wettbewerber bricksbank ja
die new developmentbank viel geringere
Voraussetzungen an Staaten zu
Kreditvergabe knüpft sie sorgen dafür
dass diese Länder in Armut gehalten
werden
Abgeordnete diese unterstellungweise ich
hier deutlich zurück wir sind einer
derjenigen die in der Welt helfen
Entwicklung voranzubringen wir sind
einer der größten Finanzierer und
diejenigen die wirklich sehr sehr gute
Initiativen und Projekte in der Welt
voranbringen und ja es gibt
schuldenumwandlung das macht zum
Beispiel Deutschland als eines der
wenigen Länder der Welt dass wir statt
neue Kredite zu geben statt neue
Unterstützung zu leisten den Ländern
anbieten Schulden wieder umzuwandeln das
ist ein sehr innovatives Instrument was
gerade für uns sehr vielen anderen
kopiert wird weil es eben nach vorne
gewann ist und weil es die Länder
voranbringt
vielen Dank und ich grüße Sie recht
herzlich in den Nachmittag und wir
kommen zum nächsten hauptfragesteller
und das ist Florian ossner
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin vielen
Dank fürs Wort meine Frage richtet sich
an den Bundesminister der Finanzen an
Christian Lindner Herr Minister sie sind
jetzt bereits seit knapp zwei Jahren im
Amt und seit zwei Jahren behaupten sie
dass sie die Arbeiten den Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in unserem Land entlasten
dabei haben sie ein teures heizgesetz
durchgeboxt sie haben die Energiepreise
mit ihrer Politik befeuert sie haben in
der letzten Woche das gastro-gesetz
nicht zugestimmt dass die
verminderten Mehrwertsteuersätze in dem
Gastronomiebereich bleiben und damit
auch die den Besuch in der Wirtschaft
teurer machen sie haben mit ihrer
Politik beigetragen dass die so
zialversicherungsbeiträge steigen werden
mit den Beiträgen die sie aus der Rente
und aus der Pflege nehmen und
gleichzeitig kommt jetzt im nächsten
Jahr noch die LKW Martin hinzu mit
sieben Milliarden Zusatzbelastung im
Gegensatz dazu möchten Sie die nicht
arbeiten nennen mit einer massiven
Erhöhung des Bürgergeldes
wie passt das zusammen bitte erklären
Sie diesen Widerspruch
ja lieber Kollege osner zunächst wollen
wir festhalten dass die reduzierte
Mehrwertsteuer für die Speisegastronomie
in diesem Jahr bereits ausgelaufen wäre
weil die Vorgängerregierung sie
befristet nur gewährt hat und für das
Jahr 2023 keinerlei Vorsorge im Haushalt
getroffen hat dafür dass sie fortgesetzt
wird zum anderen
zum anderen
will ich jetzt nicht im Einzelnen die
Genese der energiepolitischen Lage
unseres Landes darstellen sie hat sich
jedenfalls nicht innerhalb der letzten
zwei Jahre ergeben konkret hatte ich
bereits ausgeführt dass der CO2-Preis
jetzt unterhalb des preispaares steigt
der ursprünglich vorgesehen war mit dem
inflationsausgleichsgesetz haben wir
eine der größten Entlastungen der
letzten Jahre erreicht eine vierköpfige
Familie mit 55.000 € zu versteuern dem
Einkommen zahlt 800 € weniger Steuern
als in diesem Jahr beim Regelsatz des
Bürgergeldes am besten nicht mit Politik
sondern mit Statistik zu tun so ist das
eben die Kosten steigen dort im
Warenkorb deshalb ist es ja auch richtig
dass wir den steuerlichen
Grundfreibetrag also was nicht
versteuert wird an Einkommen im nächsten
Jahr dann ebenfalls an die Inflation
anpassen Gerechtigkeit also für
diejenigen die Solidarität erfahren und
für die anderen die sie bezahlen
und der Kollege Osmar sie haben die
Möglichkeit zu einer Nachfrage vielen
Dank für die Möglichkeit der Nachfrage
ich möchte schon einmal festhalten
werden letzte Woche den Antrag eben zur
Beibehaltung zu Entwicklung der
gastrosteuer gestellt wo wir den
Haushalt 23 zur Vorsorge 24 sind sie er
verantwortlich aus zuständiger Minister
nicht die Vorgängerregierungen man kann
das nicht immer abschieben
für den für das Haushalts für das
Haushaltsjahr 2022 kommen noch gut
erinnern haben sie versprochen im
Bereich der kalten Progression auch die
Entlastung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
vorzunehmen das ist bisher nicht
vollzogen worden ganz im Gegenteil sie
haben die eingesparten Gelder zum
Stopfen von Haushaltslöchern und zu
Sanierung ihres Haushalts verwendet wir
rechtfertigen Weise
wie ich dargestellt habe wir haben mit
dem inflationsausgleichsgesetz eine sehr
breite Maßnahme auf dem Weg gebracht um
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu entlasten
in dem Zusammenhang erwähne ich dann
auch noch die Erhöhung des Kindergeldes
auf 250 € für alle Kinder ist die größte
Entlastung gerade für die Familien in
den vergangenen Jahren wir haben uns
hier also nichts vorzuwerfen was ihren
Vorschlag angeht die Gastronomie auch
jetzt schon heute oder letzte Woche zu
entscheiden letzte Sitzungswoche das
kann nicht unabhängig von der
Gegenfinanzierung geklärt werden deshalb
wird ja der Haushaltsgesetzgeber
entscheiden wenn wir die Steuerschätzung
Oktober vorliegen haben sie waren zu
früh
und ich habe drei Nachfragen
als erste
ja danke Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrter
Minister Lindner sie hat mir eben meine
Frage die geht in den Themenkomplex rein
nicht beantwortet sind sie bereits
angesichts der Schilderung eben zum
einen die Entfernungspauschale für die
normalen Menschen die da draußen jeden
Tag zur Arbeit fahren deutlich zu
erhöhen und zweitens wir haben es eben
zitiert das zeigt ihre realitätsferne
eine Familie etwa 55 000 brutto verdient
indem ich die Inflation von 7 % und in
diesem Jahr von 6 %. da haben wir
ungefähr 15 % Entwertungen dieser 55000
€, das sind 725 € und da sprechen sie
über 800 € davon dass sie diese Menschen
entlastet haben also das glaube ich ein
Witz oder haben sie das zu korrigieren
und machen das Jahressteuergesetz in
diesem Jahr noch ich höre auch das kommt
erst im nächsten Jahr das ist auch in
einer Kommunismus danke ja sehr geehrter
Herr Kollege Gottschalk wenn Sie hier
auf die Inflationsentwicklung und die
Kaufkraft verweisen dann muss ich sie
allerdings daran erinnern dass wir nicht
nur das Steuerrecht haben dass wir
anpassen sondern wir haben daneben
natürlich auch die Tarifentwicklung
den Löhnen und Gehältern und nicht
zuletzt hatte die Bundesregierung ja den
Vorschlag gemacht einer steuerfreien
inflationsprämie von den viele Millionen
von der viele Millionen Beschäftigte zur
Dämpfung des kaufkraftverlustes
profitiert haben über eine Entscheidung
bei der
Entfernungspauschale kann ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht sagen
gegenwärtig gibt es dort keine Pläne und
die nächste Nachfrage hat Franziska
Obermann
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister ich musste auch noch mal
nachfragen sie haben im
Koalitionsvertrag das Klima Geld als
Entlastung für die Bürger für die
Belastung angekündigt haben aber vorhin
auf eine Frage geantwortet sie brauchen
noch die gesamte Legislatur um den
Mechanismus dafür aufzustellen und
können die Auszahlung erst in der
nächsten Legislatur vornehmen das haben
sie vorhin so gesagt da steht im
konkreten Widerspruch zum
Koalitionsvertrag und ist wieder keine
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wie erklären Sie diesen
Widerspruch
Frau Kollegin es ist keiner und ich
hatte eben auch wie das Protokoll zeigen
wird ausgeführt dass die Absicht der
Koalition war in dieser
Legislaturperiode einen
pro-kopfauszahlungsmechanismus zu
schaffen etwas was es in Deutschland
nicht gibt nie gab worüber andere aber
verfügen und das für die nächste
Legislaturperiode die Nutzung dieses
Mechanismus beabsichtigt war wir seitens
des Finanzministeriums werden ich sage
mal diese Lücke in unserer öffentlichen
Verwaltung aber schneller schließen als
geplant noch 2025 könnte eine erste
Auszahlung erfolgen und anders als
früher geplant früher war ja geplant
dass die Einnahmen aus dem CO2-Preis
komplett in den KTF gehen
und die letzte Nachfrage hat Herr
Brandner
hatte ja vorhin die befristete Senkung
der Mehrwertsteuer bei der Gastronomie
leicht Leistungen ins Feld geführt und
da haben sie zurecht die Schuld auf die
Vorgängerregierung Vorgängerregierung
geschoben bei ihrer Regierung war es ja
so dass sie die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas
und Fernwärme von 19 auf 7% gesenkt
hatten und das ganze befristet bis
31.03.2024 so weit so gut jetzt sieht
ihre Entlastung so aus dass sie diese
Senkung überhaupt rückgängig machen
wollen sie wollen also die
Mehrwertsteuer von 7 auf 90% wieder
erhöhen das ist für mich jetzt keine
direkte Entlastung und das auch noch 3
Monate eher wie geht das denn ein Herr
mit ihren Heeren Zielen zu sagen wie
entlasten die Bürger in Deutschland wenn
sie Mehrwertsteuersenkung zurücknehmen
und zwar auch noch vorzeitig
diese Reduzierung der Mehrwertsteuer bei
Gas entfernt Wärme war nie als eine
dauerhafte Maßnahme angekündigt worden
es war immer eine befristete Maßnahme in
der Krise beschlossen zu einem Zeitpunkt
als die weitere Entwicklung der Preise
nicht prognostiziert werden konnte und
aus diesem Grund haben wir uns dazu
entschlossen die damaligen
Szenarien für den schlimmsten Fall sind
nicht eingetreten zum Glück auch dank
der Umstellung der Versorgung
gleichzeitig wirken weiter die
preisbremsen bei Strom und Gas die
werden nach der Absicht der
Bundesregierung ja verlängert so dass
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger geschützt
sind vor einer ruinösen Situation
[Applaus]
vielen Dank und die nächste
hauptfragestellerin ist für Bündnis 90
die Grünen Katrin Henneberger
dank meine Frage geht ein Ministerin
Schulze aufgrund der Klimakrise werden
global die Wetterextreme immer häufiger
und stärker weshalb vor einem Jahr auf
der UN Klimakonferenz der Laus und
damagefond beschlossen worden ist mit
Blick auf die nächste unklimakonferenz
wird sich die Bundesregierung auch für
eine klimagerechte Ausgestaltung des
Fonds einsetzen wie wird sichergestellt
dass besonders betroffene Gemeinden als
auch
vaginalisierte Bevölkerungsgruppen
direkten Zugang erhalten und ist
Deutschland als Industrienation auch in
einer besonderen Verantwortung als
Geldgeber voranzugehen
Kollegin herzlichen Dank für die Frage
ja das war eine wichtige Ergebnis der
letzten Klimakonferenz das in dem
Bereich Schäden und Verluste mehr
passieren muss dieser lost and damage
Fund ist ein wichtiges Ergebnis und wir
haben mitgeholfen indem wir mit den
vulnerabelsten Staaten mit den V20 ein
globalen Schutzschirm gegen klimarisiken
entwickelt haben das ist jetzt
beispielhaft dafür was mit dem Fond
passieren soll insofern ist das was wir
einbringen das was wir in den
Vorarbeiten und den Zulauf auf diese
Konferenz gemacht haben jetzt ganz
wichtiger Bestandteil der Verhandlung um
diesen Fond wir Verhandlung laufen wir
bringen uns da sehr aktiv aus der
Bundesregierung heraus ein
sie haben die Möglichkeit einer
Nachfrage
Blick auf die
Wetterextreme die bereits heute
stattfinden wie beispielsweise in Libyen
oder vor einem Jahr im Park ist dann ist
es ja besonders wichtig dass auch sehr
schnell Gelder bereitgestellt werden und
neben der öffentlichen Finanzierung
welche Verantwortung sehen sie besonders
bei der fossilenindustrie bei fossilen
Großkonzernen ebenfalls genossen und
demisform mitzutragen
[Applaus]
erstmal würde ich absolut unterschreiben
dass uns uns gelingen muss dass die
Hilfssysteme zur Verfügung stehen bevor
die Katastrophe eintritt weil wir wissen
dass es immer mehr Überflutungen immer
mehr dürren geben wird und müssen
deshalb die Unterstützung schon bereit
haben bevor etwas passiert deswegen
investieren wir in diesem globalen
Schutzschirm gegen klimarrisiken der
eben schon die ersten Staaten ja
ausgewählt hat die wir ganz konkret
unterstützen ich halte das aber auch für
ganz zentral dass wir mehr Geld für
diesen Bereich organisieren werden eben
schon eine kurze Diskussion über das
Lenken von privaten Finanzströmen in die
richtige Richtung und das muss
sicherlich auch in diesem Bereich
passieren
vielen Dank ich sehe keine weitere
Nachfrage zu dem Thema dann komme ich
zum nächsten
hauptfragesteller das ist Markus
frohnmeyer
Frau Ministerin ich würde gerne mit
Ihnen über Ihr Engagement in Indien
sprechen viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der
Welt jetzt erfolgreich auf dem Mond
gelandet Sie und Ihr Haus aber auch die
Bundesregierung unterstützen Indien mit
10 Milliarden Euro für erneuerbare
Energien sie fördern da konkret
Sonnenkollektoren Windrädchen und Erik
Shirts gleichzeitig nimmt Indien
russisches Gas ab dass wir nicht mehr
abnehmen aber immer noch bezahlen und
kauft dieses Gas dann teurer nach Europa
und Deutschland zurück können Sie mir
bitte die Kohärenz ihre
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit an der Stelle
mal darlegen
das hat eine hohe Konkurrenz weil wir
wollen nicht abhängig sein von einem
einzelnen Staat beim Aufbau von
erneuerbaren Energien in Deutschland und
zurzeit sind wir abhängig von
solarpanälen aus China und deswegen
macht es durchaus Sinn mit anderen
Staaten Vereinbarungen zu treffen und zu
versuchen dort weitere Produktion von
z.B solarpanälen aufzubauen Indien ist
dort sehr aktiv und dort Kredite zu
vergeben und darum geht es wir haben
Kredite zu vergeben mit eben dann
günstigen Konditionen die sonst in
diesen Ländern nicht möglich sind diese
Kredite helfen dass diese Industrie
aufgebaut wird sie bringen das Land
voran und sie helfen international das
ist sehr sinnvoll eingesetztes Geld
und die Nachfrage noch gern mit
erfolgreichen Alternativen meinen sie
dann wasserstoffpartnerschaften mit
Marokko Marokko dass ich nicht mal jetzt
während einer schwierigen Situation mit
einer Flutkatastrophe helfen lassen
möchte meinen sie das quasi dann mit
erfolgreichen Alternativen wenn man
jetzt schon feststellen kann das Starten
die selbst unsere botschafterausweisen
nicht mit uns als zuverlässige Partner
zusammenarbeiten wollen
Abgeordneter auch hier behaupten sie
Dinge die so nicht sind marokko hat bei
der humanitären Hilfe nicht sofort bei
allen Staaten nachgefragt dass sie dass
sie unterstützen weil sie das nicht
koordinieren konnten sie fragen jetzt
aber beim Wiederaufbau ganz gezielt bei
uns nach und natürlich Frauen wir
langfristig Partnerschaften mit den
Ländern des afrikanischen Kontinentes
haben weil wir werden langfristig auf
Handel auf Austausch mit diesen
wachsenden innovativen Staaten
angewiesen sein und ja je mehr
erneuerbare Energien auf diesem
Kontinent hergestellt werden
dass das davon etwas in Form von
Wasserstoff exportiert werden kann
vielen Dank und wir haben eine Nachfrage
aus der FDP-Fraktion von Knut gerschau
wir sprechen gerade über Wasserstoff und
Wasserstoff spielt ja eine
Schlüsselrolle
insbesondere grüner Wasserstoff aus den
Partnerländern unserer
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit wenn eben
dieser globale Wasserstoff Hochlauf
richtig gemacht wird ist der Bevölkerung
und zwar in den Partnerländern aber auch
unsere nationalen Klimaschutzzielen
meine Frage in welchen Partnerländern
sieht das BMZ die ersten haben
schnellsten
vorausschreitenden Projekte und wie es
unsere Entwicklungszusammenarbeit dort
draufgestellt partnerschaftlich mit den
Regierungen vor Ort und mit den
Unternehmen die das wie die Projekte
umsetzen
Abgeordneter ganz herzlichen Dank für
die Frage ich würde Ihnen absolut
zustimmen es ist eine mehrfache
Gewinnsituation wir können helfen in den
Ländern Wasserstoffproduktion aufzubauen
wir helfen erneuerbare Energien
aufzubauen was jeweils der lokalen
Versorgung auch dient und mittel und
langfristig wird das auch dazu führen
dass uns Wasserstoff geliefert werden
kann deswegen haben das
Wirtschaftsministerium und das
Entwicklungsministerium gemeinsame Fonds
aufgelegt die im privatwirtschaftliches
Engagement dafür fördern und helfen und
unterstützen dass solche Infrastrukturen
ähm auf den Weg gebracht werden Kenia
ist eines der Länder die da schon sehr
erfolgreich sind vielen Dank und eine
Nachfrage noch von Dietmar Friedhof
zum Thema Wasserstoff Afrika hat ja ein
generelles Problem das ist der Zugang zu
saure und Trinkwasser die Frage richtet
sich an sie insofern ist es sinnvoll in
einem auf einem Kontinent
wasserstoffexperimente zu machen die der
deutschen Wirtschaft nutzen aber
vermutlich dem afrikanischen Kontinent
nicht indem Sie Zugriff auf das
Trinkwasser haben bei einer Anhörung
wurde uns gesagt ja man kann das auch
mit Salzwasser machen also hoch Energie
intensiv das Problem ist wenn ich es mit
Salzwasser mache brauche ich in
salzungsanlagen für Wasserstoff süßes
Wasser und da wird nämlich in Afrika die
Salzlauge wieder ein riesen Einfluss auf
die Biodiversität erklären Sie mir das
mal im Zusammenhang
so Herr Abgeordneter auch hier stimmt
die Grundannahme nicht es ist nicht so
dass bei allen afrikanischen Ländern
grundsätzlich zu wenig Wasser vorhanden
ist es gibt auch Länder die reiche
Wasservorkommen haben das ist eine
Entscheidung die jeweils in den Ländern
getroffen wird und wir unterstützen da
wo Wasserstoffproduktion möglich ist wir
werden natürlich nicht damit mit dem
Engagement was wir tun zusätzliche
Probleme bereiten sondern wirklich da
helfen wo das partnerschaftlich mit den
Ländern gemeinsam entwickelt wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und ich habe noch zwei Nachfragen zu dem
Thema das ist Herr Brandner und dann
noch Herr Dr Christoph Hoffmann
angefangen mit Herrn an ja danke schön
der Kollege frohnmeyer hat mich dazu
gebracht mal kurz nachzuschauen die
größten Volkswirtschaften auf der Erde
und da sind wir mit Indien tatsächlich
fast gleich auf vier Billionen Euro
Bruttoinlandsprodukt in den fliegt zum
Mond Deutschland eher nicht und nach
Indien kommen Großbritannien was das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt angeht Frankreich
und Kanada vor dem Hintergrund können
Sie mir kurz erklären warum wir
ausgerechnet Indien Entwicklungshilfe
von 10 Milliarden Euro im Jahr zahlen
aber Kanada Großbritannien und
Frankreich die ja von ihren
inlandsprodukten deutlich weniger
erwirtschaften nicht
ich habe das eben schon kurz erläutert
dass wir an Indien Kredite vergeben die
bisher auch sehr souverän wieder
zurückgezahlt werden das ist ein Teil
eines Aufbaus einer partnerschaftlichen
Beziehung die wir zu Indien unbedingt
brauchen es ist eine der größten
Demokratien dieser Welt und es macht
einfach Sinn mit diesem Land in engem
Kontakt zu stehen und deswegen werden
wir das auch in Zukunft tun wir werden
die Probleme dieser Welt wir werden den
Klimawandel nicht ohne den Beitrag von
Indien lösen können
[Applaus]
der letzte die letzte Nachfrage von
Herrn Dr Christoph Hoffmann zurückkommen
zum Thema Wasserstoff Afrika ist kein
Land es gibt verschiedene Länder und
manche haben sehr viel Wasser und gute
Chancen auch aus Hydro Energie
Wasserstoff zu produzieren die eine
Win-Win-Situation hervorrufen könnte die
Frage ist aber auch inwieweit die
Elektrizität im eigenen Land verwendet
werden kann und meine Frage an Frau
Schulte ist welche Win-Win-Situationen
können sich in dem Zusammenhang
vorstellen
Abgeordneter er sich erstmal kann ich
Ihnen absolut zustimmen afrika ist ein
Kontinent mit sehr vielen sehr
unterschiedlichen Staaten darauf und
deswegen müssen wir auch individuell
jeweils in den Partnerschaften sehen was
die besten Lösungen sind der Gewinn
besteht darin dass wir helfen
Energienetze vor Ort aufzubauen das
ermöglicht eine Stromversorgung für die
Menschen die heute noch nicht an Energie
angeschlossen sind das sind immer noch
viel zu viele damit kann dann und mit
dem Aufbau erneuerbare Energien können
dann Wasserstoff zum Beispiel auch für
die Mobilität für die Industrie in den
Ländern produziert werden und wenn das
erstmal alles etabliert ist werden durch
die viele erneuerbare Energie die da ist
eben auch Überschüsse produziert werden
können die dann auch wieder für den
Export zur Verfügung stehen
vielen Dank und die nächste der nächste
Hauptfrage Stelle ist für die
SPD-Fraktion dr Thorsten Rudolf
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine Frage
geht an den Bundesfinanzminister
die Diskussion hat ja auch gezeigt wie
wichtig es ist dass wir Haushaltsmittel
gerade in Zeiten knapper Kassen
effizient und effektiv ausgeben es hat
sich die Koalition vorgenommen dass wir
den Bundeshaushalt auf eine ziel- und
wirkungsorientierte Haushaltsführung
umstellen Bundesrechnungshof hat das
jetzt neulich kritisiert weil die
notwendigen Erfolgskontrollen um dieses
Ziel dann zu erreichen fehlen würden
deswegen an Sie die Frage gerade als
haushaltsminister was die getan haben
und weiter zu tun gedenken um diese
Umstellung auf eine Ziel und
wirkungsgerichtete Haushaltsführung zu
schaffen damit wir dann auch die Mitte
wirklich effizient effektiv ausgeben und
sehr sehr zielgerichtet die Politik
Felder die wir umsetzen wollen die
Politik die wir erreichen wollen dann
auch erreichen zu können vielen Dank
ja sehr geehrter Kollege Rudolph sie
wissen aus den Beratungen des
Haushaltsausschusses wo wir
verschiedentlich auch auf Fragen der
cdu/csu-fraktion darüber gesprochen
haben dass wir das Verfahren der
spending Reviews sehr ernst nehmen und
weiterentwickeln wir ziehen da auch Rat
mit ein wir gehen jetzt in
einem besonderen Zugang auf die
Nachhaltigkeitsziele der Bundesregierung
und prüfen die einzelnen etas darauf in
wie weit ihr Ausgabeverhalten das
Erreichen der Nachhaltigkeitsziele
erreichen dabei werden einzelne etas
auch im Sinne von Pilotprojekten in
besonderer Weise auch budgetieren und
wir hoffen dass wir diesbezüglich rasch
auch noch weitere Fortschritte machen
können um mit dem Geld der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger besser umzugehen
vielen Dank für die Möglichkeit einer
Nachfrage wenn Sie möchten
gibt es weitere Nachfragen zu dem Thema
das sehe ich nicht dann ist die nächste
hauptfragestellerin Ina Latendorf
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin noch mal
eine Nachfrage an Frau Schulze wir haben
ja in der UN auch das Recht auf Grund
und Boden
sozusagen festgelegt das liegt ja
natürlich an den Staaten die dieses
Recht durchzusetzen wir haben im Bereich
der der des globalen Südens große
Schwierigkeiten der Selbstversorgung und
insofern möchte ich Sie fragen wie der
Beitrag dazu ist das Recht auf Grund und
Boden für die Einheimischen doch stärker
durchzusetzen weil wir sehen da massives
Land Grimming um die ernährungsrealität
letztlich gewährleisten zu können weil
wir sehen ja das was sozusagen von außen
reingetragen wird reicht erstens nicht
zweitens kommt nicht an was zugesagt
wird wenn wir die Getreide Lieferung aus
der Ukraine sehen von denen nur
nachweislich tatsächlich nur drei
Prozent
südlichen und östlichen Afrika ankommen
obwohl viel mehr versprochen wird
insofern meine Frage welche Maßnahmen
werden
getroffen auch durch ihr Haus um zu
verhindern und Ernährung zu Realität zu
unterstützen
wir unterstützen aus meinem Haus sehr
stark darin
landwirtschaftliche Produktion in den
Partnerländern voranzubringen und dabei
vor allen Dingen auch darauf zu achten
dass diejenigen die die Haupt
ernährerinnen sind das sind nämlich die
Frauen dass die vor allen Dingen auch
Rechte bekommen weil das ist eines der
Hauptprobleme Frauen die Land
bewirtschaften im Fall einer Katastrophe
Dürre oder sonst was alles verlieren und
weil ihnen das Land nicht gehört dann
eben keinen Kredit aufnehmen können und
deswegen sind Landrechte das eine starke
Bewegung auch in vielen afrikanischen
Ländern Landrechte im voranzubringen
eines der zentralen Projekte die wir mit
unterstützen in der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
und sie haben die Möglichkeit für den
Nachfrage
ja vielen Dank Frau Ministerin könnten
sie das hinsichtlich der der Region oder
der Länder in denen sie da aktiv sind
spezifizieren
das können wir gerne noch mal
nachreichen aber wir sind in den meisten
Partnerländern auch im Bereich der der
landwirtschaftlichen Produktion
unterwegs und versuchen dort
Landwirtschaft zu unterstützen sondern
dass die Länder wieder stärker selber in
der Lage sind sich zu ernähren und eben
nicht abhängig sind von Lieferungen aus
dem Ausland
vielen Dank und wir haben eine Nachfrage
von Wolfgang steffinger und unsere
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin ich muss jetzt hier nochmal
nachfragen weil sie jetzt gerade wieder
sagen was sie hier alles im Bereich der
Landwirtschaft machen aber wenn ich den
Haushaltsentwurf anschaue dann haben wir
hier massive Kürzungen auch bei der
sonderinitiative Agrar beispielsweise
massive Kürzungen und ich möchte da
jetzt schon noch mal dran auch erinnern
dass sie das jetzt mal darlegen wie sie
das dann machen wollen und vor allem sie
haben vorher meine Frage nicht
beantwortet wie sie denn dann die
Aufwüchse im Bereich
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit finanzieren wenn
Sie bei allen anderen Dingen Armut
Bekämpfung oder jetzt auch bei Agrar
kürzen müssen
[Applaus]
Abgeordneter der wir sind einer der
größten Finanzierer weltweit wir sind
eines der wenigen Länder was die 0,7
Prozent oder Quote überhaupt Einheiten
wir sind diejenigen die gerade in der
Ernährungsbereich sehr stark finanzieren
und es werden wir auch weiterhin tun und
sie sehen das im Haushalt das machen wir
in den regierungsvereinbarungen in den
bilateralen Gesprächen wir machen das
nicht nur über sonderinitiativen und
nicht nur über einen krisentitel der
krisentitel ist derjenige der für das
zur Verfügung steht was wir jetzt noch
nicht wissen was unerwartet ist wo wir
schnell reingehen müssen und da habe ich
abgesenkt ja aber wir werden in der
Ernährung weiterhin einer der großen
Finanzierer sein und die nächste
Nachfrage kommt von Deborah Döring
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin es wurden
ja gerade die Themen der Landrechte
angesprochen wir haben heute im
Ausschuss schon intensiv darüber
diskutiert und daran anschließen weil es
ja auch ein großer Faktor ist oder eine
große Verbindung gibt zwischen
Landrechten und der feministischen
Entwicklungspolitik würde ich Sie bitten
dass sie vielleicht noch mal genauer
erklären können welche Konnektivität es
zwischen der Stärkung von Landrechte und
der Stärkung von Landrechten gibt
ja Frau Gärtner herzlichen Dank
schwierig in 30 Sekunden aber das
allerwichtigste ist das vor allen Dingen
Frauen eben diejenigen sind die das Land
bewirtschaften und wenn Ihnen das Land
nicht gehört dann haben sie einfach
nicht die Möglichkeit langfristig zu
planen und das ist aber in der
Landwirtschaft ungemein wichtig dass Sie
planen können dass Sie wissen welche
Einnahmen sie haben dass wenn es zu
Katastrophen kommt sie im Zweifelsfall
mal ein Darlehen aufnehmen können und
das stärker voranzubringen das ist ein
Teil der Politik die wir dort machen
mehr Rechte mehr Ressourcen mehr
Repräsentanz von Frauen ist das was
entscheidend ist um Entwicklung
voranzubringen
und die nächste Nachfrage kommt von
Gottschalk
ja Frau Ministerin ich habe mal
Entwicklungstheorie und Politik studiert
und da gibt es zwei Grundsätze und sie
segeln mit ihrer Politik um was sie hier
allem Hohen Hause erörtern sorgenfreien
ein Dingen vorbei sie haben eben zum
Beispiel erwähnt die Landwirtschaft muss
angekurbelt werden die Frauen müssen
gestärkt werden Sie wissen aber schon
und reden vielleicht mit den Kollegen
der EU dass unsere hohen Subventionen im
landwirtschaftlichen Bereich dazu führen
dass die Überproduktion dieser
Lebensmittel nach Afrika geht uns die
gesamten Märkte mit dieser so
hochgepriesenen EU entsprechend ruiniert
haben das lohnt sich gar nicht es ist
nämlich Marktwirtschaft kommt
man oder vielleicht auch
gendergeschlecht und der zweite Punkt
kriegen sie die Geburtenraten in den
Griff weil auch da steht drin so lange
die Geburt hat über der Wirtschaft über
den Wirtschaftswachstum liegt werden Sie
dieses Problem niemals in den Griff
bekommen und das knüpft an einem
Brandner an
Abgeordneter es lohnt sich im Kampf
gegen Armut und Hunger zu investieren
weil das hat was mit Gerechtigkeit in
dieser Welt zu tun dass wir dort helfen
und es lohnt sich vor allen Dingen da in
die Frauen zu investieren weil das
nachweislich wissenschaftlich das ist
was die Entwicklung am besten
voranbringt und natürlich lohnt es sich
in den Partnerländern die wir haben auf
dem afrikanischen Kontinent zu helfen
dass sie sich selbst versorgen können
das ist ein ganz wichtiger Faktor für
diese Länder und ich kann ihn nur raten
schauen Sie sich das vor Ort an dann
werden sie die Rückmeldung bekommen dass
Deutschland eines der Länder ist die
dort am stärksten helfen
und die letzte Nachfrage ist Matthias
Hauer
der Frau Präsidentin Frau Ministerin ich
würde Ihnen gerne mal Zeit verschaffen
weil sie gerade nach ihren Haut mit
ihren Ausführungen die zweifache Frage
meines Kollegen steffinger nicht
beantwortet haben sie sparen beim Thema
Bekämpfung des Hungers in der Welt
gleichzeitig machen sie mehr Ausgaben in
ihrem Ministerium für
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit wieso geben Sie
mehr Geld für Öffentlichkeitsarbeit aus
[Applaus]
Abgeordneter ich muss in dem krisentitel
Sparen bei dem Titel wo es darum geht
auf sich auf unerwartete Dinge
vorzubereiten und ja wir geben ein
kleines bisschen mehr aus für
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit das ist aber
notwendig weil wir auch in Deutschland
für das werben müssen was wir dort tun
wir haben auch die Aufgabe für die
globalen Nachhaltigkeitsziele und für
das Engagement was wir in der Welt
leisten in Deutschland aufzuklären das
ist ein wichtiger Teil der Arbeit den
ich eben auch erfüllen möchte
vielen Dank und die nächste
hauptfragestellerin ist für die
Unionsfraktion dr Inge kressler
vielen Dank ich möchte einen
Bundesfinanzminister eine Frage stellen
ihr FDP-Generalsekretär hat ja den
Koalitionspartner die Grünen als
Sicherheitsrisiko bezeichnet das
konsequent des Regierungshandeln
erschwere da kann man sich die fehlende
Zustimmung der Bundesregierung etwas
europäischen asyllösungen vorstellen ich
frage sie als Minister dieser
Bundesregierung der damit auch
mitverantwortlich ist für die
Positionierung der Bundesregierung und
für die aktuelle Migrationspolitik
teilen Sie die Einschätzung ihres
Generalsekretärs und wie lange schauen
sie denn dann noch zu im Bundeskabinett
danke für eine Antwort
[Applaus]
ich bin zwischenzeitlich zuversichtlich
dass die Bundesregierung dem asylpaket
auf der europäischen Ebene zustimmen
wird damit wird an grundlegender
Paradigmenwechsel verbunden sein vom
Schutz der europäischen Außengrenze über
die
Vereinfachung der Asylverfahren die
Verlagerung der Stellung eines
Asylantrags in den Bereich außerhalb der
Europäischen Union und damit wird
grundlegendes verändert was seit 2015
nicht möglich war um Kontrolle in Europa
zu erreichen kann jetzt möglich werden
und deshalb wird die Bundesregierung
vollumfänglich ihrer Verantwortung
gerecht
und haben die Möglichkeit für eine
Nachfrage
ja auch wenn Sie die natürlich will ich
nachfragen die
aktuelle Zuwanderung ist mehr als
doppelt so hoch wie die aus dem Jahre
2015 nur mal zum sagen durch die ganze
Zeit Verzögerung entstehen zusätzliche
Kosten sie haben keine zusätzliche
Vorsorge im Bundeshaushalt getroffen wie
werden sie denn mit den erforderlichen
Mehrausgaben umgehen wann treffen Sie
diese Vorsorge danke schön
Frau Kollegin im Unterschied zur
damaligen Situation haben wir einen sehr
großen Teil von Menschen die zu uns
flüchten die nicht in das
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz gehen
sondern in das Bürgergeld mit
unmittelbarem Arbeitsmarkt Zugang
nämlich jene die aus der Ukraine kommen
die Unterstützung für diese Menschen
findet sich also im Etat des BMAS im
Bereich des Bürgergeldes und wir wollen
die Arbeitsmarktintegration verbessern
darüber hinaus beteiligt der Bund sich
im Wege der gesamtstaatlichen
Verantwortung auch an den Leistungen der
Länder für geflüchtete zum Beispiel aus
Afghanistan und Syrien obwohl deren
Unterstützung kompetenziell durch das
Grundgesetz der Ländern zugeordnet ist
gibt es Nachfragen dazu
eine Nachfrage
[Musik]
apropos Kosten für das Thema Migration
wir haben schon mal ein bisschen
zurücklegen mit vielen Fragen
versuchte herauszukriegen von der
Bundesregierung die gesamtstaatliche
Kosten und zwar die jährlichen Kosten
für das gesamte
migrationsbewältigungsgeschehen
selbstverständlich über alle Ebenen des
Staates klar ist dass die Bundesebene
natürlich nur ein Teil dabei ist die
Bundesebene hat uns damals immer für
verschiedene sie wissen das alles gar
nicht und Sie können das auch gar nicht
sagen denn es sein ja die anderen Ebene
betroffen und die Zahlen hätten wir
glauben dass nicht dass sie die Zahlen
nicht haben wenn sie sich hätten würden
würde das für eine problematische
Verwaltung halten wenn sie sie haben und
nicht sagen glauben wir sind kein guter
Umgang es war aber eine
Vorgängerregierung er sei kein kommen
Sie bitte zu Ihrer Frage lautet also
können sie die herrlichen Kosten
allereringen beziffern wir kamen nach
vielen Berechnungen zu etwa 50 bis 25
dementieren
Herr Kollege tatsächlich sind Bund und
Länder in der Haushaltsführung
voneinander unabhängig deshalb haben wir
auch keinen direkten Einblick in die
Haushalte der Länder und müssen uns oft
genug auch aus öffentlichen Quellen
bedienen deshalb kann man grob
veranschlagen dass die Größenordnung die
sie genannt haben zu hoch liegt aber das
bedeutet nicht dass die Kosten
illegaler Migration nach Deutschland
nicht unakzeptabel hoch wären ich füge
aber hinzu es gibt auch Kosten unter
bliebener qualifizierter ein nach
Deutschland denn wenn Arbeitsplätze
nicht besetzt werden können weil
Menschen fehlen verlieren wirtschaftung
und die letzte Nachfrage hat Matthias
Mittelberg
sie preisen das so und tun so ein
bisschen so als ob sie da nicht
verantwortlich wären aber unser Eindruck
ist seit zwei Jahren gucken sie der
Entwicklung eigentlich tatenlos zu sie
kommen auch nicht voran bei der
Integration der Menschen die jetzt hier
sind bei der größten Flüchtlingsgruppe
der Syrer stellen wir fest gerade 32
Prozent arbeiten
sozialversicherungspflichtig 55%
beziehen Bürgergeld und jetzt streichen
Sie auch noch die eingliederungsmittel
bei der Bundesagentur für Arbeit und sie
streichen die Mittel bei der
Integrationsberatung ist das nicht die
völlig falsche Politik sie müssen doch
die Menschen arbeiten bringen
[Applaus]
im Mittel merkt zunächst dann müssen wir
differenzieren es gibt Menschen die
wandern qualifiziert ein und die können
direkt im Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung
stehen es gibt solche die Wandern ein
und müssen warten bis ihr
Berufsabschluss endlich anerkannt wird
oder wo bis Qualifikationsdefizite oder
Sprachdefizite überwunden wird aber es
gibt auch eine dritte Gruppe und bei
dieser dritten Gruppe müssen wir endlich
erreichen dass diejenigen die illegal
nach Deutschland gekommen sind
schnellstmöglich zurückgeführt werden in
das Herkunftsland und da unternimmt
diese Bundesregierung endlich mehr
Anstrengungen
vielen Dank und damit sind wir am Ende
der
Befragung der Bundesregierung die Zeit
ist auch vorüber vielen Dank und wir
kommen zum Tagesordnungspunkt 2 der
Fragestunde
die mündlichen Fragen auf Drucksache 20
84 48 werden in der üblichen Reihenfolge
auch aufgerufen
ich rufe auf den Geschäftsbereich des
Bundesministeriums für Wohnen statt
Entwicklung und Bauwesen zur
Beantwortung steht bereit der
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin war
toll
und ich rufe auf bitte Sie entsprechend
die Plätze einzunehmen
und ich rufe auf die Frage Nummer eins
des Abgeordneten Bernd Schattner zum
Thema Vorantreiben der
Entbürokratisierung im Bauwesen durch
die Bundesregierung Herr Staatssekretär
sie haben das Wort frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Abgeordneter ich
beantworte Ihre Frage wie folgt die
Bundesregierung hat eine Vielzahl von
Maßnahmen ergriffen und das Bauen zu
vereinfachen und zu beschleunigen und
das Beteiligungsverfahren in der
Bauleitplanung wurde mit der Anfang Juli
2023 in Kraft getretenen Baugesetzbuch
Novelle auf ein digitales Regelverfahren
umgestellt die Bundesregierung
unterstützt zudem die Einfuhr des
digitalen bauantragsverfahrens durch die
Bundesländer mit dem Gebäudetyp e soll
ein einfaches und experimentelles bauen
ermöglicht werden die Einführung einer
folgekostenabschätzung für Baunorm
treiben wir mit der Einrichtung einer
unabhängigen Prüfstelle voran in
Kommunen mit angespannten
Wohnungsmärkten sollte dem mit einer
generalklause der Bau von bezahlbaren
Wohnraum für alle vereinfacht und
beschleunigt werden angelehnt an die
Sonderregelungen paragraph 40 Absatz 14
Baugesetzbuch und befristet bis zu 26
das Bundesministerium für Wohnstadt
Entwicklung und Bauwesen wird die
Änderung des Baugesetzbuches noch in
diesem Jahr vorlegen mit einer
experimentierklausel in der TA Lärm
bekommen die Kommunen mehrspielraum
Bayern Gewerbegebiete heranrückender
Wohnbebauung
und sie haben die Möglichkeit für zwei
Nachfragen vielen Dank Frau Vorsitzende
der staatsregitär kommen wir noch kurz
zum baugipfel den wir diese Woche hatten
da gibt es ja diesen 14 Punkteplan wo
auch die Entbürokratisierung eine Rolle
spielt und da spricht jetzt der
Bundeskanzler davon dass wir eine
Rekordsumme von 18 Milliarden zur
Förderung des Wohnbaus in den
verschiedenen Preiskategorien zur
Verfügung stellen dieses Summe steht der
Baubranche allerdings bis einschließlich
dem Jahr 2027 zur Verfügung das heißt
wir sprechen dann davon dass wir hier
von 4 Milliarden pro Jahr sprechen wenn
wir das Jahr 2023 komplett
unberücksichtigt lassen reicht ihrer
Meinung nach oder der Meinung der
Bundesregierung nach dieses Summe dafür
überhaupt aus die IG BAU fordert ja in
diesem Bereich alleine 50 Milliarden im
Vergleich dazu haben wir zum Beispiel
alleine seit Kriegsausbruch für die
Ukraine 22 Milliarden zur Verfügung
gestellt
ja ja Abgeordneter Schattner ich glaube
nicht dass wir diese beiden Dinge
miteinander aufrechnen sollten Sie
nehmen vielleicht zur Kenntnis dass das
eine Rekordsumme ist wir hatten kurz
nach dem Krieg mal eine höhere wir haben
die Mittel für den sozialen Wohnungsbau
auf Rekordhöhe angehoben sie wissen dass
für das Bereitstellen von bezahlbaren
Wohnraum die Länder in der föderalen
Ordnung zuständig sind wir helfen den
Ländern dabei dieses Ziel zu erreichen
die Länder finanzieren ko wir haben eine
Verwaltungsvereinbarung es gibt Länder
die Hebeln dieses Geld um ein Vielfaches
so dass natürlich am Ende auch eine viel
höhere Summe bis zu 40 Milliarden über
40 Milliarden Euro zustande kommen
und die zweite Nachfrage bitte noch
bleiben wir dann in dem Bereich einfach
dabei sie haben ja gerade festgestellt
Kunst oder ich stelle fest günstige
neubaukredite für Familien mit geringem
Einkommen waren ja so gut wie nicht
nachgefragt in den ersten zwei Monaten
dieses Jahres gab es lediglich 104
Anträge in diesem Bereich da geht es
hier die Baubranche dass das vollkommen
unrealistisch ist bei einer
Einkommensgrenze von 60.000 Euro sich
hier noch ein Baukredit leisten zu
wollen Familien die mehr verdienen
wurden da nicht mehr berücksichtigt
jetzt wird ja nach dem baugipfel die
Grenze minimal angehoben auf 90.000 €.
damit wird dann werden dann sind
verbilligte Kredite in Höhe von bis zu
170.000 € von der KfW möglich wenn man
allerdings sieht dass der Mittelwert bei
Neubau Kosten je Quadratmeter für
klimafreundliche neu gebauten laut
Schwäbisch Hall momentan aktuell bei
3.792 Euro liegt könnte sich damit eine
Familienhaus mit 43 Quadratmeter leisten
wie wollen Sie dazu versorgen dass junge
Familien künftig dann in diesem Bereich
sich überhaupt bauen noch leisten
können und entsprechende adäquate
Wohnraum zur Verfügung steht und wie
passt das zusammen mit dem
Energiestandard eh 40 mit ihren
Klimazielen wenn sie ja dann kommen Sie
bitte zum Schluss werden
Abgeordneter auch hier gilt dass ich es
nicht geringfügig finde wenn man das um
30.000 Euro anhebt von 60 auf 90.000 wir
reagieren darauf dass der Mittelabfluss
auch aus unserer Sicht zu gering ist
wollen wir natürlich mehr Menschen zum
eigenen Eigentum verhelfen wollen
deswegen ändern wir jetzt möglichst
schnell auch sehr rasch die Konditionen
das wird auch mehr Menschen eigenes
Eigentum ermöglichen und davon sind wir
überzeugt sonst hätten wir das nicht
vorgeschlagen
eine Nachfrage von Herrn Brandner aber
bitte auch zum Thema
nur warum haben sie da Zweifel Frau
Präsidenten die Nachfragen waren schon
nicht wirklich zum Thema von daher also
gut jetzt ganz konkret zum Thema
endbürokratisierung tut Not und ich
glaube wir sind doch einig dass in
Bürokratisierung Not tut in Bezug auf
serielles bauen also mit anderen Worten
Stichwort Fertighaus vorgefertigte Teile
zusammenfügen da habe ich Kontakt zu
innovativen Geistern und die sagten mir
also da würde gerade das Gegenteil von
endokratisierung stattfinden Stichwort
honigwabentechnik das wäre ein riesen
Problem in ihrem Ministerium UHPC Beton
wäre ein riesen Problem das genehmigt zu
bekommen also bezogen auf diese beiden
Dinge uh PC Beton und honigwabentechnik
wie entbürokratisieren die da konkret
also erstens Herr Abgeordneter für die
Genehmigung auch von neuen Baustoffen
ist dass er DBT zuständig das kennen Sie
sicherlich und wenn es da Probleme gibt
können die von Ihnen genannten
Gesprächspartner sehr gerne auch an mich
wenden die Frage wie wir das ganze
vereinfachen und beschleunigen deswegen
haben wir eine Geschäftsstelle gegründet
für das serielle modulare und
systemische bauen
bei der Stiftung bei unserer
Bundesstiftung Bauakademie wir haben
dort in verschiedenen working groups
jetzt die Arbeit voll aufgenommen um das
serielle modulare bauen voranzutreiben
das beginnt alles sehr vielversprechend
und wir wollen ja genau das serielle
bauen in die Breite bringen aber eben
nicht wie sie sagen im Sinne von
althergebrachten Denkmustern sondern als
wirkliche echte Alternative auch zum
normalen bauen
vielen Dank dann kommen wir zur zweiten
Frage
das Abgeordneten Bernd Schartner Stand
der Entwicklung der Urbanisierung in
Deutschland
lieber staatsanit
sehr Abgeordneter frau Präsidentin ich
antworte wie folgt der generelle Trend
zur Organisierung national wie
internationales weiterhin ungebrochen
die Wanderungsgewinne der Großstädte
haben sich seit dem 2000er Jahren
kontinuierlich aber verringert die
Bundesregierung setzt sich für die
Herstellung gleichwertiger
Lebensverhältnisse überall in
Deutschland ein mit der
Städtebauförderung stärkt der Bund
zusammen mit den Ländern die nachhaltige
Entwicklung von Städten und Gemeinden
für das Jahr 2023 sind der 1997
Millionen Euro Bundesmittel vorgesehen
bezahlbarer Wohnraum für alle ist eine
entscheidende Voraussetzung für
gleichwertige Lebensverhältnisse die
Bundesregierung hat daher aktuell ein
Maßnahmepaket für zusätzliche
Investitionen in den Bau von bezahlbaren
und klimagerechten Wohnraum und zur
wirtschaftlichen Stabilisierung der Bau
und Immobilienwirtschaft auf den Weg
gebracht
sie haben die Möglichkeit für zwei
Nachfragen ja vielen Dank viele
Großstädte in Deutschland sind ja
mittlerweile geprägt durch eine
zunehmende räumliche Aufspaltung in
Reichenviertel mit guter Infrastruktur
und ahnenviertel in denen die Bewohner
ein extremer sozialer politischer und
wirtschaftlicher Ausgrenzung Leben in
diesem Kontext stellen sich auch Städte
die in hohem Maß Flüchtlinge aufnehmen
aber auch Flüchtlingslager die über
Jahrzehnte hinweg dauerhaft Strukturen
entwickeln zunehmend lokale und
gesamtgesellschaftliche
Herausforderungen da die KfW stellt
jetzt ein Hilfsprogramm aus Eigenmittel
bereit und hat dafür den Sinn
verbilligten Kredit wegen der hohen
Nachfrage auf ein Volumen von insgesamt
500 Millionen aufgestockt das soll
Städten und Kommunen helfen die
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte schaffen oder
modernisieren und ausstatten gerade auch
in größeren Städten sind aus Sicht der
Bundesregierung weitere Steuergelder
nötig um hier die Finanzierung von
flüchtlingsunterkünften zu stemmen
aufgrund der hohen zuzugszahlen die wir
aktuell sehen
er Abgeordneter selbstverständlich
müssen wir weiterhin darüber reden ob
das was uns das ganze kostet angemessen
aufgerufen wird dazu finden wir auch
Gespräche der staatlichen Ebene
miteinander auch statt ich glaube auch
der Bundesfinanzminister dazu gerade
einiges auch ausgeführt am Ende habe ich
ja gerade die Städtebauförderung erwähnt
und genau das ist ja das Instrument wie
wir gegen städtebauliche Missstände auch
Vorgehen die übrigens auch nicht immer
was mit Flüchtlingen zu tun haben aber
mit Migration zu tun haben sondern das
haben sie selber angesprochen auch etwas
mit der Einkommensverteilung in diesem
Land zu tun haben mit der Frage des
auseinanderdriften zwischen Arm und
Reich da müssen Sie nur den Amazon
reichtumsbericht hineinschauen und dafür
haben wir einen sehr zielgenaues
instrument was ich bewertet hat weil es
auch alle Ebenen adressiert
und die zweite Nachfrage hat noch gerade
ältere Menschen haben ja mittlerweile
aufgrund von soziale Isolationen mit der
Urbanisierung zu kämpfen viele geraten
aufgrund der Wohnungsnot in all das
Armut oder sogar in die Obdachlosigkeit
derzeit sind aktuell in Deutschland
262.600 Menschen ohne Wohnung
38,5 und 38.500 Personen bleiben
tatsächlich auf der Straße die anderen
finden derzeit noch private Unterkunft
oder in öffentlichen Einrichtungen fast
die Hälfte genau 47% der wohnungslosen
Menschen ohne Unterkunft unter verdeckt
wohnungslosen Menschen die schon mal
eine eigene Wohnung besaßen haben ihre
Wohnung ausschließlich bzw auch aufgrund
von Mietschulden verloren wie möchte die
Bundesregierung diesen negativen
Entwicklungen entgegentreten und
gleichzeitig den Flüchtlingsstrom der
eine weitere Überbevölkerung der Städte
zur Folge hat begegnen wäre hierbei
nicht viel sinnvoller Stadt über eine
migrationsobergrenze zu sprechen
rimigrationsoffensive zu starten wir
haben aktuell 300.000 ausreichend
Pflichtige Ausländer fakt ist doch
schließlich auch auch Abschiebungen
schaffen Wohnraum vielen Dank
ja Herr Abgeordneter ich finde es sehr
schade weil ich fand sozusagen ihre
anfängliche Problembeschreibung der
Menschen ohne Obdach ohne
Wohnungslosigkeit sehr hervorragend und
wollte ihn eigentlich danken dafür dass
sie das Thema hier reinbringen weil ich
finde schon dass ich ein reiches Land
wie Deutschland um dieses Thema mehr
kümmern muss und deswegen hat diese
Koalition ja auch ein will ein
Aktionsplan gegen Wohnungslosigkeit
auflegen sie wollten wissen bis 2030
wollen wir versuchen möglichst
Wohnungslosigkeit und Obdachlosigkeit zu
überwinden da arbeiten wir gerade sehr
intensiv daran dass sie das jetzt wieder
in einen Sinn Zusammenhang stellen mit
Migration und Flüchtlingen Mark
notwendig sein bei ihm er ist aber finde
ich in dieser Frage überhaupt nicht
Sachen und fachgerecht weil sie wissen
auch es gibt viele persönliche
Lebenslagen die dazu führen dass man auf
der Straße landet oder dass man sein
Obdach verliert ich finde ihn Hinweis
auf das soziale Mietrecht sehr wichtig
und auch darum wird sich diese Regierung
kümmern
und ich habe einen Nachfrage zum Thema
ich sag noch mal das Thema heißt
opernisierung in Deutschland und eine
Nachfrage von Frau Maschek
weil sie vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrter Herr staatsretär wir haben
ja auch Leerstand in Innenstädten in
Deutschland und gestern oder vorgestern
ich weiß nicht genau vorgestern gab es
im wohnungsbaugipfel bzw das Bündnis für
bezahlbares Wohnen und welche Ergebnisse
sind da oder welche Vorschläge sind da
entstanden für die Bekämpfung des
Leerstandes und eine bessere
Durchmischung in den inzentren unserer
Städte
ja Frau Abgeordnete vielen Dank
wir haben uns im Bündnis mit diesen 187
Maßnahmen mir sehr intensiv beschäftigt
und eine der Maßnahmen ist es Leerstand
zu aktivieren weil sie haben recht es
gibt Regionen in Deutschland die sind
eben nicht komplett voll sondern da
herrscht jetzt noch Leerstand und wir
müssen die Faktoren identifizieren die
mithelfen können diesen Leerstand wieder
nutzbar zu machen das kann das
Bundesbauministerium nicht alleine da
gibt es auch andere Ministerien die noch
mithelfen müssen ich sage so ein
Stichwort wie Mobilität die Frage der
Erreichbarkeit von diesen Wohnung aber
auch die Fragen von Arbeitsplätzen die
notwendig sind um in diesen Gegenden
dann auch vernünftig leben und wohnen zu
können deswegen wollen wir da auch haben
wir auch beschlossen einen Aktionsplan
zur Lehrstand Aktivierung wo wir uns
auch mit der Bundesregierung insgesamt
sehr intensiv auch im Rahmen des
Bündnisses mit diesem Thema beschäftigen
werden
und die letzte Nachfrage von Herrn
beckamp
ja vielen Dank es geht ja um die
Urbanisierung insofern haben wir eine
durchaus große Urbanisierung und große
Wellen von ja neuen Bürgern und das
führt ja auch zu sehr gemischten
Quartieren im Rahmen der Urbanisierung
insofern die Frage wie wird denn dem
Vorgang Rechnung getragen dass diese
gemischte Quartiere immer heterogener
eben gemischt werden und immer mehr
Konflikte auch aufbrechen gibt es dafür
auch besondere Programme besondere
Obacht der Regierung wieder mit
umgegangen wird dass eben vielleicht
auch Konfliktlinie immer mehr zu Tage
treten und das dadurch auch gerade
deutsche und andere einheimische
verdrängt werden aus den bestehenden
Quartieren und die Organisierung in eine
falsche schädliche Richtung für uns alle
läuft
ich glaube ihre Definition von
Urbanisierung ist an dieser Stelle
falsch sie beschreiben ja sie
beschreiben mir etwas ganz anderes
Organisierung ist ein sehr weitgehende
Begriff der übrigens nicht nur was mit
immer mehr Menschen in einer Stadt zu
tun hat sondern sie wissen es gibt
suborganisierung das Verhältnis Stadt
und Land sie wissen auch es gibt so eine
Art soziokulturelle Urbanisierung das
heißt dass man gewisse Dinge die man
entstehten tut dann auch auf dem Land
tut was auch wiederum Auswirkungen hat
also insofern sollten wir schon sauber
definieren worum es geht sie reden davon
dass es immer schon in der Geschichte
der Menschheit gerade seitdem wir auch
in größeren Komplexen Zusammenleben
immer so genannte ankunftsquartiere gab
es gab immer Quartiere in einer Stadt wo
Menschen die aus anderen Ländern
gekommen sind oder aus anderen Gegenden
gekommen sind erstmal angekommen sind
warum weil zum Beispiel Leute aus dem
gleichen Kulturkreis dort gelebt haben
oder vielleicht auch aus dem ähnlichen
Gegenden gelebt haben das gab es schon
immer und wichtig ist dass man das
einfach erkennt dass man es annimmt dass
man das akzeptiert und diesen
Stadtteilen dabei hilft ihre besonderen
Problemlagen auch vernünftig zu
bearbeiten das geht kann aber auch für
alle Themen das gilt für die Schulen das
gilt für das Miteinander das gilt für
die innere Sicherheit für die
Erreichbarkeit und all das tun wir
vielen Dank dann kommen wir zur nächsten
Frage der Frage Nummer drei der
Abgeordneten Karin Ley zum Thema
mögliche Pläne zur Erhöhung der
gesetzlichen des der gesetzlichen
neubaustandards mit Effizienzhaus 40 ab
2025 Herr Staatssekretär sie haben das
Wort frau Präsidentin Frau Abgeordnete
lay der er 55 Standard beim Neubau hat
sich bewährt und es Kosten tragen und
deshalb werden wir die Erhöhung auf den
er 40 Standard in dieser
Legislaturperiode aussetzen die im
Wohnungs Neubauprogramm 220 bis 24
enthaltenen geschosswohnungs Neubauten
der Bundesanstalt für Immobilienaufgaben
werden entsprechend den gesetzlichen
Vorgaben errichtet das heißt derzeit in
Bezug auf den Premier Energiebedarf
mindestens dem Effizienzhaus Standard 55
zwei nachfragen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Staatssekretär das Thema ist ja
tatsächlich auch dann behandelt worden
nach Einreichung der Frage auf dem
wohnbaugipfel nun ist es ja so dass der
Gebäudebereich neben dem Verkehrsbereich
das große Sorgenkind ist was die
Einhaltung der Klimaziele anbelangt und
jetzt haben sie mal so schnell
entschieden wir setzen sowohl eher 40
beim Neubau aus für die gesamte
Legislatur und für alle Neubauten und
gleichzeitig auch die Sanierungspflicht
im Bestand also auch ohne irgendeine
Differenzierung mir ist jetzt nicht so
ganz klar wie dann die Klimaziele auch
im neu im Baubereich erreicht werden
sollen
Frau Abgeordnete so wie sie das jetzt
beschrieben haben ist es ja nicht wir
machen eher 40 nicht zum neuen
Mindeststandard wir fördern aber
weiterhin den eher 40 Standard zum
Beispiel im klimafreundlichen Neubau
oder eben schon angesprochenen
Wohneigentumsprogramm für Familien das
heißt es wird auch weiterhin in
Deutschland mit eher 40 Standard gebaut
und natürlich haben wir auch gerade ein
heizungsgesetz wie man sagt das Gebäude
Energiegesetz beschlossen wo wir uns ja
den Wärmebedarf genau anschauen wir
machen eine kommunale wärmeplanung und
sie wissen auch der größte Hebel zum
Einsparen von CO2 im Gebäude bestand ist
die Sanierung das ist das eine Thema da
machen wir sehr viel und natürlich auch
die ganze Frage Stichwort Lebenszyklus
Stichwort Baustoffe ich erinnere auch
mal die Holzbau Strategie der
Bundesregierung all das tun wir und all
das trägt signifikant zum Einsparen von
CO2 bei
und die zweite Nachfrage
also ich sag mal so wenn es jetzt um
eine Abwägung gegangen wäre zwischen den
ökologischen Klimazielen auf der einen
Seite und sozialen Zielen auf der
anderen Seite da wissen sie das sind
genau die Ziele die wir als LINKE auch
vertreten
ich denke allerdings dass jetzt diese
Pauschale Änderung
tatsächlich weder den ökologischen noch
den sozialen Zielen Rechnung trägt und
wäre es nicht besser gewesen an dieser
Stelle stärker zu differenzieren zum
Beispiel zu sagen okay beim sozialen
Wohnungsbau da wo tatsächlich die
neubaupreise eine soziale Vermietung
nicht mehr erlauben würden da setzen wir
es vielleicht aus aber bei dem
bundeseigenen Bauten gehen wir weiterhin
mit gutem Beispiel voran und orientieren
uns dort eben an strengeren
klimastandard wäre das nicht eine
sinnvolle Lösung gewesen deswegen ist
der Bund bei seinen eigenen
Bautätigkeiten sich an die Klima an
dieses höheren Klima Standard hält
Frau Abgeordnete die Bundesregierung
hält sich an die klimastandards sie
wissen dass die Beamer eine
eigenständige Gesellschaft ist die
übrigens vom Bundesfinanzministerium
in rechtlicher Sicht betreut wird
insofern machen wir das auch und noch
mal ich versuche es noch mal zu erklären
wir setzen eher 40 nicht aus sondern wir
erklären er 40 nicht zum Standard das
bedeutet wir bleiben bei eher 55 als
Standard und können weiterhin den eher
40 Standard fördern würden wir eher 40
zum Standard erklären könnten wir ihn
nicht mehr fördern deswegen glaube ich
unterm Strich tun wir dadurch mehr für
den Klimaschutz aber wir bringen auch
Ruhe in die Bauwirtschaft in
Immobilienwirtschaft rein wir haben
Planungssicherheit und auch das wird am
Ende da hoffentlich zu führen dass wir
mehr bezahlbaren Wohnraum in diesem Land
haben
vielen Dank ich sehe keine weiteren
Nachfrage dann rufe ich auf die Frage
Nummer vier des Abgeordneten Dr Jan
Marko lucczak zum Thema Stand der
Umsetzung des Wohnungsbau zieht jetzt
das Bundesministeriums für Boden statt
Entwicklung und Bauwesen der 20
Wahlperiode der Staatssekretär sie haben
das Wort
frau Präsidentin Herr Abgeordneter ich
beantworte das wie folgt um das Ziel von
400.000 neuen Wohnungen und 100.000
öffentlich geförderten Wohnung zu
erreichen hat die Regierungskoalition
verschiedene Vorhaben und
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart und vor
einem Jahr mit dem Bündnis bezahlbarer
Wohnraum ein Maßnahmenpaket für eine
bauinvestitions- und
Innovationsoffensive vorgelegt das
Bauministerium hat bereits den Großteil
relevant davor haben des
Koalitionsvertrags abgearbeitet und von
den Maßnahmenpaket des Bündnis
bezahlbarer Wohnraum sind schon mehr als
die Hälfte der Maßnahmen umgesetzt oder
Sie sind auf den Weg gebracht worden in
der aktuellen wirtschaftlichen Lage
bedarf es zu erreichen der notwendigen
und am Bedarf orientierten Wohnungsbau
CD jedoch zusätzlicher Kraftanstrengung
die Bundesregierung reagiert deshalb
kurzfristig auf diese Situation mit den
Geld am Montag vorgestellten 14
Maßnahmen für zusätzliche Investitionen
in den Bau von bezahlbaren und
klimagerechten Wohnraum und zur
wirtschaftlichen Stabilisierung der Bau
und Immobilienwirtschaft darunter sind
neue und gestärkte Förderprogramme
beschleunigungsmaßnahme im Rahmen des
Deutschlands Paktes oder
planungsrechtliche Erleichterung sowie
die ansteigenden Bundesmitteln für den
sozialen Wohnungsbau den Kombination mit
der Koordination der Länder dazu führen
dass Fördermittel in historischer Höhe
für die Schafe von bezahlbaren Wohnraum
zur Verfügung stehen werden
und wir haben zwei Nachfrage
Möglichkeiten ja vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin damit sozusagen eingeräumt
dass die Maßnahmen die sie im letzten
Jahr beim Bündnis für bezahlbares Wohnen
die 187 Maßnahmen obwohl diese wie sie
gesagt haben ja schon zu Hälfte mehr
oder weniger abgearbeitet sind
keinesfalls ausgereicht haben um das
Ziel von 400.000 Wohnungen was Sie sich
gesetzt haben als Koalition zu erreichen
mittlerweile ist auch klar 400.000
Wohnung ist auch gar nicht genug wir
brauchen eigentlich 500.000 Wohnungen
jetzt sprechen Sie von einem neuen
entschieden den Kraftakt den man da
braucht und das soll jetzt der baugipfel
der am Montag gewesen ist sein 14 Punkte
umfasst das Maßnahmenpaket dann würde
mich aber schon mal interessieren wie
sie eigentlich auf die Kritik reagieren
oder gar nicht Kritik oder vielleicht
einfach nur die Einschätzung reagieren
von Professor Süde kommen jetzt nicht
irgendjemand sondern immer in
Regierungsberater der sagt dieses
Maßnahmenpaket das wird gerade einmal
reichen um einen Impuls wird 30.000
zusätzliche Wohnung zu geben wenn man
jetzt weiß im nächsten Jahr gehen wir
von also nach Schätzungen von etwa
177000 Wohnungen aus die gebaut werden
können jetzt kommen da noch 30.000 hinzu
sind wir bei etwa 210.000 also Meilen
weit von den 100.000 Wohnungen entfernt
da muss man auch sagen das reicht doch
alles nicht oder sehen Sie das anders
Abgeordneter vielen Dank auch noch mal
für die für die Hilfe beim Erreichen des
wohnungsbauziels ich glaube dass am Ende
alle föderalen Ebenen jetzt ihre
Hausaufgaben machen müssen um am Ende
für mehr bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu sorgen
ich finde dass die Bundesregierung
obwohl wir ja wissen in welche
hausarterischen Situation wir sind
obwohl wir wissen in welcher
krisenhaften Situationen auch um uns rum
und in Europa wir uns gerade befinden
alles tut und diese Krise in der Bau und
Immobilienwirtschaft jetzt mit einem
klaren Impuls zu begegnen gleichzeitig
haben wir aber auch viele andere
Maßnahmen die ja nicht alle in den
Maßnahmenpaket drin stehen die auch dazu
beitragen und ich erwähnen noch mal die
Rekordhöhe der Mitte für den sozialen
Wohnungsbau all das wird dazu führen
wenn auch die anderen staatlichen Ebene
genauso engagiert und es tun sie an
diesem Problem arbeiten dass wir Stück
für Stück mehr neue bezahlbare Wohnungen
bekommen das ist das Ziel ob wir jetzt
Punkt genau die 400.000 Wohnungen
erreichen wir werden das sehen aber
wichtig ist doch wir erkennen ist wir
nehmen es an und wir kämpfen dagegen an
und die zweite Nachfrage also übersetzt
heißt das wenn das Maßnahmenpaket
genauso umgesetzt wird und
zugegebenermaßen dann müssen die Länder
auch mitwirken dann schaffen wir
vielleicht die 30.000 Wohnungen aber
nochmal um das mal rechnerisch klar zu
halten dann sind wir bei etwas über
200.000 Wohnungen also gerade einmal die
Hälfte dann würde meine Einschätzung
sein wenn man rechnen kann das reicht
jedenfalls nicht aus ich will aber noch
an einen zweiten Punkt
anknüpfen es ist ja so dass sie jetzt
gesagt haben sondern auch alle Experten
eigentlich müssen wir ja bei dem
Baukosten runterkommen weil die
Haushaltsmittel sind nicht unendlich
sondern das Bauen ist in Deutschland zu
teuer und dann ist auch wohnen
irgendwann unbezahlbar deswegen müssen
wir bei dem Baukosten jetzt sagen Sie
nun die große Errungenschaft ist dass
wir den eher 40 Standard jetzt nicht
einführen das auch schön und gut ist
auch unsere Forderung als Union weil das
ist bauen ja noch einmal teurer gemacht
hätte um etwa 10 % nur der Punkt ist ja
das Bauen ist heute schon richtig teuer
jetzt sagen Sie wir verteuern das Feuer
bauen nicht noch weiter aber Ziel wäre
doch gewesen dass bauen und die Kosten
bei uns zu senken davon finde ich in
diesem Papier leider herzlich wenig
Abgeordneter das ist jetzt ihre Wertung
ich finde da sehr viel vor allen Dingen
finde ich sehr viel was diese
Bundesregierung gemacht hat wenn sie
sich die Holzbau Strategie anschauen
wenn Sie sehen dass man mit heimischen
Rohstoffen arbeiten kann wenn Sie aber
auch sehen dass wir uns natürlich
intensiv um zum Beispiel was auch ein
Papier drin steht den Gebäudetyp eh
kümmern wenn wir gleichzeitig sagen dass
wir uns die normungsprozesse anschauen
die man sich auch anschauen muss weil
auch das verteuert bauen immer weiter
wir wollen eine folgekostenschätzung
einbauen ich habe vorhin beantwortet das
ganze Thema serielles modulares Bauen
von dem wir uns auch Effizienz gewinnen
versprechen und wenn dann auch andere
Ebenen Stichwort Grunderwerbsteuer dazu
kommen sozusagen diese Krise auch
anzunehmen und ernst zu nehmen ich
glaube dann werden wir es auch schaffen
auch die bauen Nebenkosten und andere
Dinge nach unten zu drücken
vielen Dank ich habe drei Nachfragen
einmal von Karin live
ja vielen Dank
Freunde sind natürlich die versprochenen
100.000 neuen Sozialwohnungen im Jahr
weil es ist ja nicht egal was gebaut
wird sondern es kommt ja auf bezahlbaren
Wohnraum an und sie rühmen sich ja
vollmundig damit dass es die größte
Investition seit menschheitsgedenken ist
ich will nur sagen wie sie auf diese
18,5 Milliarden gekommen sind haben sie
einfach das nächste Jahr bis 2027 mit
rein gerechnet also wir sprechen ja über
Zeitraum von fünf Jahren und da möchte
ich sie tatsächlich fragen wie sie der
Kritik begegnen dass Institutionen wie
beispielsweise der Deutsche Mieterbund
aber Teile auch der Wohnungswirtschaft
gefordert haben das ist eine
Investitionssumme die brauchen wir in
einem einzigen Jahr wie würden Sie
dieser Kritik begegnen dass man mit den
18,5 Milliarden in 5 Jahren die sie hier
versprechen eben nicht die 100.000
Sozialwohnungen in einem einzigen Jahr
bauen kann zur Erinnerung das waren
gerade mal 22
.500 Sozialwohnungen im letzten Jahr und
es sind insgesamt aber 14.000
Sozialwohnungen aus der Verbindung
gefallen das heißt
weniger wie begegnen sie dieser Kritik
der begegne ich damit Frau Abgeordnete
dass wir noch mal eine Rekordsumme
aufrufen 80,15 Milliarden Euro das hat
es seit langem so nicht gegeben das wird
Coop finanziert durch die Länder die
übrigens auch alle ihre Anstrengung
Anstrengung deutlich nach oben fahren
das heißt wir sehen doch ganz genau dass
wir eine Trendumkehr erreichen werden
weil wir das Thema sozialen Wohnungsbau
auf die politische Agenda wieder ganz
nach oben gehoben haben und dort auch
mit den Ländern ja ein intensiven
Gesprächen sind auch das für ein neues
Programm aufgelegt haben junges Wohnen
für Studenten und azubiwohnungen ist ja
auch ein klares Signal dass wir dem
gesamten geförderten Bereich ganz neue
Aufmerksamkeit schenken und das aber
nicht nur im Sinne von schönen Worten
sondern auch mit finanziell hinterlegt
und die nächste Nachfrage hat Christina
Johanni Schröder
Präsidenten
sie sind schon mehrfach darauf
eingegangen dass Bauen im Bestand
stärker in den Fokus gerückt wird das
spart einerseits Materialien und damit
Ressourcen andererseits schaffen wir
damit schnellen Wohnraum was sind die
Potenziale die wir durch
innenverdichtung durch aufstocken durch
umnutzen schaffen können und welche
Rolle spielt Zukunft dich reparieren
sanieren umbauen um nutzen zur
Beschaffung des notwendigen Wohnraums
ja Frau Abgeordnete vielen Dank es gibt
Studien wenn man das alles zusammen
betrachtet kann man über 100.000
Wohnungen reden die das bringen könnte
gerade wenn wir auch über die Frage von
Umnutzung zum Beispiel von
Gewerbeimmobilien auch reden und ich
glaube dass wir in diesem Land deine
neue umbaukultur brauchen dass wir uns
diesem Thema viel stärker widmen müssen
das tun wir auch immer Maßnahmenpaket
mit dem Stichwort
Gewerbeimmobilien das tun wir aber auch
in anderen Bereichen Stichwort Gebäude
Ressourcen passt die Frage wie man auch
durch Digitalisierung des Bauens
Stichwort building Information modeling
auch sozusagen auch Bauteile
wiederverwenden kann das heißt dieses
Thema bisschen zur Lebenszyklus
Betrachtung von Gebäuden hat eine ganz
neue Priorität und wir werden das Stück
für Stück auch umsetzen und auch durch
die Aufstockung von
Dachgeschosswohnungen und anderen Themen
die wir ja auch adressiert haben im
Rahmen des Bündnisses werden wir auch
neuen Wohnraum zur Verfügung stellen
ohne zusätzlichen Flächen verbrauchen
vielen Dank und die nächste Nachfrage
hat Tobias Peterka und dann habe ich
noch eine Nachfrage und dann schließe
ich auch die nach Fragen bei der
hauptfrage.4.hauptfrage
ja vielen Dank bei ihrem vorgelegten 14
punkte-programm da geben sie ja einige
Fehler zu muss man sagen zum Beispiel
dass die familienbauförderung aus dem
Ruder gelaufen ist dass dort kaum
abgenommen wird die Fördersumme sie
verlangen aber jetzt inzwischen
überraschenderweise auch wieder die
degressive Abschreibung und sehen damit
auch den Fehler ein dass diese eben
bisher stiefmütterlich
gehandhabt wurde und sie erwähnen die
Grunderwerbssteuer also die Nebenkosten
des Erwerbs zumindest in Thüringen wo
der die Grunderwerbssteuer kürzlich
gesenkt begrüßen Sie das also dass sich
das auf Länderebene zumindest auch so
entwickelt und würden sie vielleicht die
Senkung der Grund Erwerbsteuer auch für
gewerbliche Investoren in Betracht
ziehen nicht nur für private
wohnen Erwerber
Abgeordnete ich glaube wenn man
Maßnahmenpaket vorschlägt ist das nicht
das Anerkennen von Fehlern sondern das
ist das Reagieren auf eine Situation die
wir alle hoffentlich zur Kenntnis nehmen
nämlich dass die Bauwirtschaft die
Immobilienwirtschaft in einer tiefen
Krise steckt dass wir mehr bezahlbaren
Wohnraum brauchen deswegen legen wir
Dinge vor unter anderem auch
Steuererleichterung wir haben übrigens
nicht nur die degressive Ava wir haben
die Sonderabschreibung wir haben das
Anheben der Linien AfA auch noch das
müssten Sie auch noch aufziehen das sind
keine Fehler sondern das sind
Instrumente um auf die politische
Situation zu reagieren und wir
adressieren auch die Länder über das
Thema Grunderwerbsteuer nachzudenken wie
die Länder das tun müssen auch die
Länder selbst in ihre eigenen
Verantwortung dann auch entscheiden wir
haben über das Bundesfinanzministerium
auch den Ländern Angebote unterbreitet
wir könnten uns auch Dinge vorstellen
die man auch noch verändern kann in der
Systematik jetzt schauen wir ob die
Länder und wann die Länder darauf
eingehen aber ich glaube es ist wie
gesagt Aufgabe aller staatlichen Ebene
für bezahlbaren Wohnraum
und die letzte Nachfrage hat
frau Präsidentin Herr Staatssekretär
fakt ist viele Menschen in unserem Land
können sich kein bezahlbaren Wohnraum
leisten bis zur corona-pandemie habe ich
selbst noch auf dem Baustellen
gearbeitet war als Bauleiter tätig da
waren auch die Baukosten überschaubar
klar ist Baukosten alleine und
beziehungsweise auch neuen Wohnraum
alleine kommen nicht dazu dass sich die
Mieten sinken sinken werden was tut die
Bundesregierung im Bereich des Mietrecht
Stichwort indexmieten und vor allem
bezahlbarem Wohnraum langfristig für die
Menschen in unserem landestand haben
danke
Herr Abgeordneter vielen Dank für die
Frage zu Mietrecht ich beantworte sie
jetzt mal stellvertreten für das
Bundesjustizministerium ich glaube das
Bundesjustizministerium wird alles dafür
tun um die Dinge die wir gemeinsam
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben auch
umzusetzen umgewichtige Elemente des
sozialen Mietrechts auch weiterhin
gelten lassen zu können sich anzuschauen
wie das Thema Index Mietverträge z.B im
Moment wirkt was damit passiert man muss
ja Index Mietverträge auch nicht
abschaffen man kann sie auch
umstrukturieren das sind alles Themen
die wir in der Bundesregierung
miteinander besprechen und die wir
glaube ich auch innerhalb der Koalition
sehr intensiv miteinander besprechen
sollen
vielen Dank und wir kommen zur Frage
Nummer fünf des Abgeordneten Lars Rover
zum Thema Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung
zur Umkehr des Trends zum Zuzug in die
Städte hin zur Nutzung von wohnungs-
Herr Staatssekretär sie haben das Wort
Abgeordneter auch wenn ich gerade schon
ein bisschen was dazu gesagt habe ich
beantworte es wie folgt mit der
Handlungsstrategie leerstandsaktivierung
setzt das Bundesministerium für
Wohnstadt Entwicklung Bauwesen eine
Maßnahme des Bündnis bezahlbarer
Wohnraum zur Aktivierung des Leerstands
um ziel ist die Steigerung der
Attraktivität vor allem
strukturschwacher und ländlicher Räume
z.B durch eine verbesserte
infrastrukturelle oder verkehrliche
Anbindung durch eine
ressortübergreifende Zusammenarbeit
sollen hierbei auch bereits bestehende
Instrumente und Programme eingebunden
werden die Städtebauförderung spielt
dabei auch bisher schon eine wichtige
Rolle und am Anfang dieser Woche
vorgestellt Maßnahmenpaket der
Bundesregierung ist zudem ein Programm
vorgesehenen kauft alt für den wohnen
Eigentumserwerb im Bestand und ein
Programm zur Förderung der Umnutzung von
leerstehenden Gewerbeimmobilien
vorgesehen
die dürfen zwei Nachfragen Stellen dank
frau Präsidentin Herr Staatssekretär wir
sind ja bei diesem Thema gemeinsam
glaube ich daran dass wir in den
ländlichen Raum Menschen bewegen wollen
da Eigentum zu schaffen deswegen auch
die Frage vor dem Hintergrund des
Bundeskongresses jetzt haben sie als
Bundesregierung den 14 Punkteplan
vorgelegt und da gibt es den Punkt 12
der sich genau mit dem Thema der
Grunderwerbssteuer beschäftigt da könnte
man konkret sehr sehr schnell
das Geld oder das Bauen günstiger machen
den Eigentumserwerb günstiger machen
wenn ich das aber lese dann wird der
beschrieben in dem Punkt dass man jetzt
noch ein langwierigen Verhandlungen ist
sie haben gerade eben gefragt schauen
wir mal wie sich die Länder reagieren
können Sie mir irgendwie einen Zeitplan
vorlegen wann das möglich sein wird
warum die Bundesregierung vielleicht
nicht auch von alleine diesen Vorschlag
macht sondern jetzt noch mal in
langwierige Verhandlung geht weil es ist
ja eine optionsklausel die sie den
Ländern geben würden das könnten sie
doch auch selber beschließen
ja Abgeordneter da wir ja alle gehe ich
mal davon aus nicht nur
Bundestagsabgeordnete sind sondern auch
alle eine Heimat haben und auch in
dieser Heimat verankert sind reden wir
hier nicht über irgendwelche
Objekte sondern wir reden über den
föderalen Aufbau unseres Landes und sie
wissen auch wem die Einnahmen zustehen
und sie wissen auch dass natürlich auch
die fehlenden Einnahmen zu Konsequenzen
führen genauso wie bei uns fehlende
Einnahmen zur Konsequenzen deswegen
finde ich jetzt richtig wenn die
staatlichen Ebenen versuchen das
Miteinander zu lösen trotzdem muss ich
kein Bundesland daran gehindert fühlen
jetzt schon die Grunderwerbsteuer
abzusenken sie wissen es gibt ja ein
Korridor den man nutzen kann man muss
auch nicht den Höchstsatz nehmen man
kann auch jetzt ohne irgendeine
gesetzliche Veränderung jederzeit die
Grunderwerbsteuer senken das können die
Länder tun sie können da in ihrem Land
versorgen
und eine zweite Nachfrage
[Applaus]
Nachfragen für lang frau Präsidentin
dass sie die zulassen die
länderöffnungsklausel einen Freibetrag
einzurichten die müssten sie schon im
Gesetz schaffen sonst kann es nicht
gemacht werden und daran haben sie sich
jetzt etwas warum gedrückt deswegen will
ich immer eine Frage nachschicken welche
von den 14 Punkten ist denn jetzt sofort
umsetzbar weil wenn ich das durchlese
nehme ich war überall da ist noch
Verhandlung und da ist noch nicht alles
klar dann haben wir jetzt gerade wieder
ein Fördermittel Aufruf in einem anderen
Ministerium gehabt da war innerhalb von
nicht mal 24 Stunden das Geld alle also
wann kommen Sie denn jetzt wirklich
voran dass Sie mit diesen 14 Punkten
auch wirklich den den neuen Schwung in
die Baubranche bringen
vielen Dank Herr Abgeordneter wir leben
in einer parlamentarischen Demokratie
und die Bundesregierung kann nicht alles
für sich alleine tun ich glaube das
würden sie auch begrüßen dass das so ist
ich als parlamentarischer Staatssekretär
begrüße das übrigens auch wir ändern
sofort die Kondition bei
Wohneigentumsprogramm für Familien das
geht jetzt sehr schnell wir sind jetzt
dabei den 246 Baugesetzbuch Vorschläge
zu unterbreiten die sie natürlich dann
am Ende auch beschließen muss so gehen
wir Maßnahme für Maßnahme durch und da
wo wir schnell handeln können handeln
wir schnell da wo wir mit Ihnen
gemeinsam handeln handeln wir trotzdem
hoffentlich auch schnell aber natürlich
geht das nicht ganz alleine da brauche
ich dann das Parlament da brauchen wir
das Parlament als Bundesregierung ich
bin aber sehr optimistisch und sowas wie
z.B die Frage der Förderkulisse des
Speed Bonus das wissen sie befindet sich
auch gerade auch in den
parlamentarischen Verhandlungen und
deswegen geben wir da auch von Haus dass
das auch sehr schnell kommt vielen Dank
und ich habe zwei Nachfragen einmal von
Christina Johannes Schröder
vielen Dank Frau Präsident Kollege ruwe
hat ja in der Tat einen Punkt die
Kaufnebenkosten sind hoch und das führt
auch durchaus im ländlichen Raum dort wo
es keine gute Anbindung gibt an der
Stadt dazu dass Immobilien leer stehen
jetzt gibt es ja nicht nur die
Grunderwerbsteuer als Kauf nehmen Kosten
sondern eben auch die Notarkosten und
auch die Maklergebühren und Deutschland
hat die teuersten Maklergebühren im
europäischen Vergleich dafür ist auch
alleine die Bundesregierung also die
Bundesregierung oder die Bundesebene
zuständig welche Möglichkeiten gibt es
eben legale Gesetzeslücken zu schließen
und für Familien die Kaufnebenkosten
auch bei den Maklergebühren zu senken
ja Frau Abgeordnete ich würde jetzt
ungern sozusagen mich auf einzelne
Instrumente festlegen aber was man
vielleicht sagen kann ist dass wir in
den Maßnahmenpaket eben nicht nur von
der Grunderwerbsteuer sprechen sondern
von Bau Nebenkosten von
Erwerbsnebenkosten und ich glaube es
wäre gut wenn der parlamentarischen Raum
dazu Initiativen kommen weil ich glaube
schon dass wir sagen müssen wir müssen
den Kauf des eigenen Eigentums die
eigenen vier Wände das müssen wir
erleichtern da müssen wir uns alle
Faktoren anschauen und ich denke wir
sind gerne bereit als Bundesregierung
uns damit auch zu beschäftigen vielen
Dank und die letzte Nachfrage hat die
Kollegin
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Staatssekretär ich unterstütze
den Impuls von Herrn Rover die
ländlichen Räume zu stärken und in dem
Maßnahmenpaket der mit den 14 Punkten
waren ja auch einige Punkte dabei die
ganz konkret auf den ländlichen Raum
ausgerichtet sind jetzt ist es
allerdings so dass ein Teil der Aufgaben
die raus entstehen die muss der Bund
umsetzen ganz konkret es gibt aber auch
den vereinbarten deutschlandpakt denen
die Länder sehr begrüßen welche Punkte
sind denn konkret von den Ländern auch
beizusteuern oder wo sind die Aufgaben
noch mal die wir hier auf Bundesebene
nicht lösen können oder einfach die enge
Zusammenarbeit zwischen Bund und Ländern
brauchen
ja Frau Abgeordnete vielen Dank das ist
so in unserer Ordnung das halt die
Länder eben in diesem Bereich eine hohe
Kompetenz auch haben und die auch nutzen
müssen deswegen schauen wir ja auch alle
auf die Jubiläums bauministerkonferenz